WHEN NOT SICK BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S CORRECT MYSELF OVER
THERE. YEAH. OKAY I'LL OF OUR
STUFF IS ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY- I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB FIVE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING A TO DISCUSS DJJ
REALIGNMENT WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING HERE IN
THE HEARING WORLD AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE- IN
PERSON. WE'RE ALL BARRING MASS
WE WARRANT AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR ANY VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ
SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. IN
TODAY'S HEARINGS TO HELP ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE
TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS ALL OF OUR PANELISTS ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY TODAY FOR
REMOTE- FROM REMOTE WITNESS
ROOMS ARE OVER THE PHONE. BUT
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM HERE IN
FORCE THIRTY SEVEN YOU WE ARE
HAVING PHYSICALLY DISTINCT SO
DISTANCE IN PERSON HEARING. WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS A MINIMUM A CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER
OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE
CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. ONCE PUBLIC COMMENTS
AGAINST ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROLE WISHES TO
SPEAK THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC BACK
PHYSICAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES
AND NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE YOU'RE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. WE ARE WE
WILL BE USING MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PORTION THIS IS
CONCERNING THE REMOTE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. INSTRUCTIONS FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION WAS
PROVIDED IN ADVANCE IN THE
AGENDA FOUND IN THE ASSEMBLY
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WEBSITE. OUR
CALL IN NUMBER IS. ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THAT'S. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCENT CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THE
NUMBER IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE EACH PERSON
WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I WILL STRICTLY
ENFORCE THAT LIMIT. THOSE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
SHOULD KNOW THAT THE THAT THE
LIVE STREAM HAS A SLIGHT DELAY.
FROM THAT BROADCASTS TO THE
ACTUAL EVENT GOING ON IN THE
ROOM. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE LIKE YOUR BROADCAST LIVE
STREAM TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. YOU CAN ALSO CALL
THE COMPLETE AT AREA CODE.
916-319-2099 THAT'S.
916-319-2099 IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROP AND MY STAFF WILL BE A
BIG. WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
GIVE YOU SOME ASSISTANCE. THE
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO PLACE IN
THE QUEUE. WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD BEGINS. BUT THE
GENDER DAY WE WERE HEARING FROM
A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
PROPOSAL FOR DJJ REALIGNMENT.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED THIS
SHIFT IN THE MAY REVISION AND
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER ON A
PROPOSAL TO OPERATIONALIZE THE
SHIFT. AT I WILL ALLOW ALL
MEMBERS TO MAKE BRIEF OPENING
COMMENTS THEN TURNED TO OUR
PANELISTS WHO WILL BE PROVIDING
THEIR REMARKS OVER THE PHONE. I
WILL CALL ON EACH INDIVIDUAL TO
BEGIN THE REMARKS AND THEY WILL
BE SPEAKING IN THE ORDER LISTED
ON THE AGENDA. PLEASE BE SURE
TO STATE YOUR NAME EACH TIME
YOU SPEAK. WE ALSO ASK HAVE THE
L. A. O. AD THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TODAY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE ANY
COMMENTS THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND USEFUL TO OUR DISCUSSION.
ONCE ALL PANELS HAVE SPOKEN I
WILL TURN TO THE MEMBERS UP FOR
QUESTIONS. AT THE COLLUSION AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS I WILL OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND I WOULD
FIRST MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS FROM
THOSE IN THE ROOM AND THEN OPEN
IT UP TO THE PUBLIC. ON THE
PHONE. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS IS A NEW PROCESS
THAT WOULD LIVING THROUGH
DURING THIS TIME. BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AT
THIS TIME. I'D LIKE TO HAVE A
ROLL CALL. WEBER HERE JONES
SAWYER HERE KILEY YEAH BLACKIE.
STONE TAKING. CARE WE HAVE A
QUORUM- HERE TODAY. IF YOU'RE
COMMITTEE STILL GOING ON OKAY
I'M GOING TO GIVE OUR OUR CHAIR
AND OPPORTUNITY HAVE OPENING
COMMENTS FIRST AND THEN I'LL
MAKE SOME COMMENTS. BECAUSE I
KNOW HE HAS A COMMITTEE GOING
ON DOWNSTAIRS THANK YOU DOCTOR
BY APOLOGIZE I CAN'T STAY FOR
THIS. VERY IMPORTANT HEARING
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A HEARING
GOING ON DOWNSTAIRS AS WELL.
LET ME JUST FIRST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR THE
COMMITTEES LEADERSHIP. ON
LOOKING INTO THIS ISSUE OF DJJ-
I THINK. RETHINKING HOW WE DO
JUVENILE JUSTICE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE STAKES
ARE VERY HIGH. IF WE GET A
WRONG WE COULD SEND YOUNG
PEOPLE. DOWN A PERMANENT PATH.
IN A PERMANENT PRESENCE IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. IF WE
DO IT RIGHT. PEOPLE WILL BE
ABLE TO LIVE THEIR LIVES BECOME
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS. GET
EMPLOYMENT GET HOUSING. REALLY
BE ABLE TO CHANGE THEIR LIVES
SO THIS IS SUCH A CRITICAL
DECISION BECAUSE THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE THE STATE HASN'T
BEEN DOING IT RIGHT. THAT'S WHY
WE WORKED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR WITH
THE PROPOSAL TO MOVE DJJ AWAY
FROM CDC ARE AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES- I WOULD SAY
THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC PROPOSAL AND-
SOME OF THE DETAILS I THINK WE-
AS A LEGISLATURE. TOOK ON FAITH
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION IN
HOPES THAT WE COULD MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS SEE SOME REFORMS.
REPEAT DO BETTER BY ALL THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE SYSTEM.
WHAT'S CONCERNING IS THIS YEAR.%
THE NEW PROPOSAL TO REALIGN
MANY OF THE- THE JUVENILES INTO
OUR VARIOUS COUNTIES. AND WHILE
WE ARE LOOKING FOR COST SAVINGS
IN THIS AREA. THE COST SAVINGS
COME BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE RETURN. IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN THE
SYSTEM THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING TO BE PENNY WISE AND
POUND FOOLISH. WE REALLY NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE MAKING
THE PROPER INVESTMENTS TODAY SO
WE SAVE THE DOLLARS DOWN THE
ROAD SO INSTEAD OF. USING OUR
TAX DOLLARS. ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS BECOME TAXPAYERS.
AND SO I THINK THIS IS A VERY
CRITICAL DECISION TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE NOT AGAIN TRYING TO
SAVE MONEY TODAY AND SPEND
MONEY A LOT MORE MONEY DOWN THE
ROAD. HELLO WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A PROPOSED OFFICE OF YOUTH
JUSTICE AT HHS THAT THIS
PROVIDES A GOOD OPPORTUNITY IN
A GOOD PLACE FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT IN THE RIGHT
PROGRAMS I THINK THERE IS A
CONCERN ABOUT. HOW THIS
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTIES
WILL GO. OUT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT WERE FOCUSED TOO MUCH ON
EACH INDIVIDUAL DOLLAR RATHER
THAN THE OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROGRAM. I THINK WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT AGAIN WERE
NOT. FOCUSED ON COST CUTTING IN
ORDER TO. IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT TIS PRODUCT IS A BETTER
PRODUCT IN THAT WORK PROPERLY
SERVING. THESE CUSTOMERS. WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO DO BETTER BY
ALL THESE YOUNG FOLKS WE'VE
SEEN NOW OVER THE LAST FEW
DECADES THE MISTAKE THAT WE
MADE. WE THOUGHT THAT IF WE
COULD JUST INCARCERATE PEOPLE
FOR LONGER. SOMEHOW THAT
SOCIETY WOULD BE SAFER HAS
IMPROVE THE NECESSARY THE CASE.
ALL IT HAS IS GROWN THE BUDGETS
OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AT TE EXPENSE OF BEING AT THE
FRONT HEALTH CARE. THE FUND
EDUCATION BE ABLE TO FUND OUR
UNIVERSITIES BE ABLE TO FIND
THE MOST CRITICAL SERVICES THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE DEMANDING
IN ASKING FOR. TODAY SO AGAIN I
THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS
FOCUS ON WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING. TO PROPERLY SERVE. THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE. SO THAT THIS IS
THE ONE AND ONLY STEP IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
DOESN'T LEAD THEM DOWN A
PERMANENT PATH. I THINK WE HAVE
TO THINK VERY HARD ABOUT WHAT
ARE THE PROPER SERVICES. THAT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE THEM AT THIS
YOUNG AGE SO THAT THEY CAN GET.
THE HELP TO TURN THEIR LIFE
AROUND. I FULLY BELIEVE THE
GIVEN THE RIGHT OPPORTUNITY
THAT MANY OF THEM AND MOST OF
THEM WILL BE ABLE TO DO THAT. I
THINK AT THIS POINT AS STATE WE
HAVE FAILED. IT HAVE A- THE
SERVICE. AND THOUGHT. WE SEE
THEM LATER ON A LIFE AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR ADULT
PRISONS SO WITH THAT LET ME
JUST THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER FOR
CHAIRING THIS HEARING VERY
EXCITED ABOUT HEARING FROM THE
ADVOCATES AND KNOWING THE
RESULTS OF YOUR DELIBERATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DAMAGE TO TANKS- WILL COME A
LONG WAY. WITH DJJ- MANY YEARS
AGO IT WAS CALLED TO SEE WHAT A
WHICH WAS THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
AUTHORITY. WE HAVE MORE MOVE
MORE THAN TEN YOUTH PRISONS
WHEN WE HAD MORE THAN TEN YOUTH
PRISONS AT OVER TEN THOUSAND
INCARCERATED YOUNG PEOPLE. NOW
WE HAVE THREE FACILITIES AND
EIGHT HUNDRED YOU'VE- LAST YEAR
WE SUPPORTED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MOVE DJJ TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. ISSUED ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED TO CLOSE THE J. J.
AND WE ALL USE LOCALLY. IT
SEEMS RIGHT THAT SUCH A SMALL
SYSTEM SMALLER THAN A MIDDLE
SCHOOL CAN BE A OF A RELYING TO
THE COUNTIES. BUT IT ISN'T JUST
ABOUT DJJ REALIGNMENT IT'S
ABOUT D. J. J'S REALIGNMENT THE
RIGHT WAY. COUNTY SEVEN HAILING
THE BEST JUDGE OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO COME TO. WHO COULD BE SENT
TO DJJ. BUT THEY'RE KEPT
LOCALLY SO WE KNOW THAT IT CAN
BE DONE. WHILE WE MAY SUPPORT A
REALIGNMENT YOU THROUGH THE
COUNTY WE'RE NOT REALIGNING THE
RESPONSIBILITY OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WITH FIFTY
EIGHT DIVERSE COUNTIES
OVERSIGHT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE NOT CREATING
JUSTICE BY GEOGRAPHY. WE WANT
THE CONSISTENT DELIVERY OF
EXCELLENT REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING STANDARDS ARE ARE
ADHERED TO ANDDATA IS
COLLECTED TO MEASURE PROGRESS.
RACIAL DISPARITIES CONTINUE TO
BE A PROBLEM AS BLACK AND BROWN
YOUTH ARE OVER REPRESENTED AT
ALL STAGES OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE. OVERSIGHT OF PROGRAMS
AND PRACTICES CAN HELP TO
REDUCE THESE DISPARITIES. I DO
NOT SYSTEM IS A BETTER SYSTEM
THAN IT WAS TEN YEARS AGO BUT
WHAT WE DO WITH THIS PROPOSAL
WILL HELP DETERMINE WHETHER WE
CAN CONTINUE ON THIS POSITIVE
TRAJECTORY. WELL THIS IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE CARES VERY MUCH
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
RIGHT GOALS AND SAFEGUARDS ARE
IN PLACE. AND OUR PRIMARY GOAL
HERE ISN'T TO SAVE MONEY WHEN
THE LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
AT STAKE IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO WHAT'S RIGHT WHAT'S
RESPONSIBLE. TO DO THAT RIGHT.
BONTA INPUT FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SO THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THIS TOGETHER AND MAKE THE
PROGRESS SO ESSENTIAL FOR TO
OUR CHILDREN. I'D LIKE TO OPEN
UP ANY MA'AM WHERE ANY MEMBER
WHO LIKE TO HAVE A COMMENT
WE'RE ASKING TO LIMIT OUR-COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES SO
THAT WE CAN GET TO OUR OUR- OUR
OUR PANEL. IT WOULD HAVE ANY
COMMENTS YES MR JONES SAWYER.
AND THEN MISTER STONE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER FOR HIS HEARING ON IT
REALLY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
WHEN THE GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
FIRST PROPOSED TRANSFERRING TO
DIVISION. OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
TO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY I WAS BOTH
EXCITED FOR THE PROPOSED
POTENTIAL INCREDIBLE. CONCERNED
ABOUT LIMITATION. I TEMPTED TO
CONVENE MEETINGS WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND STAFF AND OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUES THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND RELEVANT
STAKE HOLDERS. SO WE COULD
BEGIN DISCUSSING ISSUES OPENLY
AND CHART A COURSE FOR THIS
SHIP. WHICH WERE NOT INCLUDED
TO JOIN THESE MEETINGS. FOR
INTO A CONVERSATION FIVE. RIGHT
AS A GROUP. THIS IS. JOINING US.
I LEARNED THAT WE SPEND NEARLY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. KID IN DJJ.
I STILL HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN A
JUSTIFICATION. FOR THAT FIGURE.
AND I BELIEVE THE OUTCOME FOR
OUR YOUTH DO NOT MATCH THE
INVESTMENT THAT WE ARE MAKING
AS A STATE. I AM SO CONCERNED
ABOUT OUTCOMES FOR OUR YOUTH
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR STATE
INVESTMENT. THAT LAST YEAR I
REQUEST AN AUDIT AND A SEPARATE
SOURCE OF FOR JUVENILES ON
PROBATION. THE OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN COUNTIES
RECEIVED ANNUALLY INDIVIDUAL
JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT. THAT AUDIT
SHOWED WHAT IS UNFORTUNATELY
ALL TOO COMMON THAT THERE IS
MINIMAL OVERSIGHT. ON THE USE
OF THESE FUNDS COUNTY'S
EXERCISE. LEVELS BUT GENERALLY
MINIMAL ACCOUNTABILITY FINE. AN
OUTCOME. ARE NOT. AND THAT IS
WHY PLEASE. TO BE PART OF THIS
CON. TODAY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO SHIP THE YOUTH. IN
DJJ AND A THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER YOUTH AND ANNUAL
FUNDING TO COUNTIES WITHOUT ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IS
UNACCEPTABLE. OUR MOST VALUABLE
YOUTH ARE TOO IMPORTANT FOR US
TO LET THEM SLIP LET THEM SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE ARE
FAILING TO DEMAND BETTER. I
SUPPORT PROPOSALS TO CLEARLY
OUT IT SPEAKS CLEARLY SPELL OUT
WHAT WE EXPECT TO RECEIVE AS A
STATE FOR INVESTMENT IN YOU
SERVICES. I AM TIRED OF YEARS
OF BATTLING OVER WHO RECEIVE
FUNDS INFIGHTING BETWEEN
PROBATION LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
NONPROFITS OVER STATE DOLLARS.
WE NEED TO SET CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS OF WHAT OUTCOMES
WE WANT TO SEE AN INCREASE
READING LEVELS. IT RESET.
IMPROVE HEALTH AND STABLE
HOUSING ETCETERA WITH THESE
CLEAR GOALS COUNTIES CAN
DISTRIBUTE FUNDS TO WHOMEVER
THEY BELIEVE CAN PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. BUT SHOULD KNOW THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR
OUTCOMES AT THE STATE LEVEL
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTED IN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED MY LEGISLATION. TO STOP
REFERRING TO YOUTH AT RISK AND
REPLACE TO PRAISE WITH AT
PROMISE. WE DID THIS TO
HIGHLIGHT AND UPLIFT THE
INHERENT POTENTIAL IN EACH OF
THESE YOUTH. AND NOT CONTINUE
TO BEAT THEM DOWN DUE TO THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES OR BRING. IF WE
TRULY WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
PROMISE OF THE USE OF THESE
ISSUES THEN WE MUST START DOING
BETTER BYE. IT SAID OFTEN THAT
OUR BUDGET IS A STATEMENT OF
OUR VALUES. TODAY WE LIVE WITH
LUCKILY WE VALUE OUR AT PROMISE
YOUTH AND WILL NO LONGER ALLOW
THEM TO SUFFER BECAUSE WE AS
ADULTS. HAVE NOT DONE OUR JOBS
WE CAN DO BETTER. WE MUST DO
BETTER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MR STONE. THANK YOU
ACTUALLY EXCITED. AT THE
PROSPECT WILL CERTAINLY LAST
YEAR THE THOUGHT OF MOVING DJJ
TO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IN
FACT DJJ PROBABLY. STARTED
THERE. DECADES AGO. AND NOW
WE'RE SORT OF JUMPING TO.
REALIGNING YOUTH SERVICES OUT
TO COUNTIES AND IF THE REASON
THAT'S BEING DONE IS PURELY
FISCAL WE WILL FAIL THESE YOU
THERE IS AN ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT. SO I
APPRECIATE THE WORK AT THE
COMMITTEES DONE AND HAS BEEN
DOING OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS. TO CREATE A MUCH
STRONGER FRAMEWORK BECAUSE THIS
IT HASN'T ABSOLUTE INTEREST IN
ENSURING CONSISTENCY. L. AND
BEST PRACTICES ACROSS ALL OF
THE COUNTIES AND THAT HAVE TO
BE BUILT INTO THIS PROPOSAL OR
WE WILL FAIL THOSE YOU THERE'S
REALLY NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
WE NEED TO HAVE APPROPRIATE
LICENSING REGULATORY AUTHORITY
BUT THAT DOESN'T NEED TO BE
SEPARATE FROM. THE THAT THE
THINK TANK ASPECT OF WHAT A AT
AN AGENCY THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
COULD DO WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT IS IF WE END UP WITH
IT MATTERING WHERE A CHILD
THAT'S IN TROUBLE AND IS BEING
SERVED. IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN WE
HAVE FAILED OUR YOUTH IN THIS
STATE SO HAVING A- THE ABILITY
FOR THE STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SEEING. APPROPRIATE
LEVELS OF SERVICES ACROSS THE
BOARD IS ABSOLUTELY PARAMOUNT
WE ALSO DJJ AS YOU MENTIONED
THAT I'M SURE HAS MADE SOME.
STRIDES OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS AND THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING THE
SEX OFFENDER PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE AND OTHERS. THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
REPLICATE COUNTY BY COUNTY BY
COUNTY. N. WE NEED A REGIONAL
APPROACH OR EVEN ARGUABLY ACE
STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT OF A
PROGRAM THAT SO THOSE ARE THE
DETAILS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FILL IN. OVER TIME AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ULTIMATELY HAVE
ANSWERS TO SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US ACROSS THE
STATE AND I NOTED IN TALKING TO
PROBATION CHIEFS THERE ARE.
SOME THAT ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS SOME THAT ARE VERY WORRIED
AND WHAT THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
THE MOST AYE I THINK IN TALKING
THEM IS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE SHORT CHANGED AND LEFT
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES. TO
ADEQUATELY PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THE- THE USE THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO SERVE AND- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
HAVE TO SAFEGUARD WITH I AGREE
COMPLETELY WITH THE NOTION THAT
IF WE MAKE THE RIGHT
INVESTMENTS. AND WE CREATE AN
APPROPRIATE STRUCTURE NOW THE
SAVINGS WILL CALM BUT IF WHAT
WE DO TODAY IS SEEN MERELY FOR
THE LAND. OF FISCAL GIVING THEN
THIS IS GOING TO EXACERBATE THE
CITY AND THAT HAVE BEEN CLOSE
TO SLEEP TRYING TO IMPROVE.
UNITY THAT THIS HAS TO BENEFIT
OUR YOUTH ACROSS THE STATE AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
THE BEST PATH FOR THEM TO GET
OUT OF THE SITUATION THAT THAT
THEY HAVE FOUND THEMSELVES IN.
AND ULTIMATELY IF WE CAN BRING
THEY- THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
THE PROBATION SYSTEM ALL OF THE
SYSTEMS TOGETHER. AND DEAL WITH
YOU. IN A WAY THAT THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO BARRIER TO ANYONE
GETTING THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES THEY NEED TAKE THE
STIGMA AWAY FROM THE JUSTICE
INVOLVED YOUTH AND JUST MEET
THEM WHERE THEY ARE PROVIDE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDE.
THAT THE- FOR THAT THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES WE
ALTERNATELY NOT ONLY SAVE MONEY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
IMPORTANT YES BUT WE SEE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF THAT AND
YET FOR HOWEVER WE GET IN
CONVERSATION. WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE WE KEEP ON
TRACK WITH OUR ULTIMATE GOAL OF
REDUCING OR SET OF. IN LIVES
EVEN TO PROVIDE BENEFITS OUR
YOUTH ACROSS. THANK THANK YOU
STONE IS THERE ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A COUPLE OF MINUTES FOR
OPENING. OKAY THAT BEING THE
CASE I WANT TO THANK OUR
MEMBERS FOR THEIR COMMENTS WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PANEL WE HAVE
SOME OF. VERY INTERESTING AND
EXCITING INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING
TO SPEND SOME TIME TALKING TO
US WE'RE HOPING AND WE'RE
ASKING EACH PANELIST MET THEIR
COMMENTS TO FIVE MINUTES AT THE
MOST. YEAH BUT THE- SEVEN. SO
WE TO THE WE GET A CHANCE TO
HEAR THE MALL AND THEN HAVE
SOME COMMENTS CONCERNING. OF
THEIR- OF THEIR STATEMENTS
WE'RE GONNA BEGIN WITH
ELIZABETH CALVIN WHO IS A
SENIOR ADVOCATE OF THE
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS DIVISION AT
HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH. AND DOES
SHE WILL BE OUR FIRST TO
PRESENT OUR FIRST PANELIST.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU. FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY. THIS IS A MOMENT FOR
CHANGE ONE THAT REQUIRED
CALIFORNIA INVEST IN YOUTH
JUSTICE AND THE FUTURE OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE YOUNG PEOPLE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE
YOU THE COLOR. OF THE STATE WE
MUST CONFRONT THE POLICY
CHOICES THAT HAVE RESULTED IN
UNCONSCIONABLE INEQUITIES IN
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. BLACK BROWN
AND INDIGENOUS YOUNG PEOPLE
BEAR THE BRUNT OF OUR STATE
MOST PEOPLE JUSTICE SYSTEM
DECISIONS THE STATE MUST MAKE A
CHOICE FOR MORE MONEY INTO A
SYSTEM THAT HAS CONSISTENTLY
FAILED YOUTH OF COLOR AND OUR
COMMUNITY. OR GIVE IT THE RIGHT
WAY PAVING THE WAY FOR A SPRING
BASED APPROACH. ALL THE J. J.
WE URGE POLICY. TO DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY. THE BROOMSTICKS HOME
BECAUSE CLOSER J. J. IF NOT
DONE WITH CAREFUL PLAN IT'S
COOL WILL CALIFORNIA. RAY IT'S
RECENT YEARS SIX IN REDUCING OF
YOUTH TO A COURT THAT'S FIFTEEN
IN PART BECAUSE DJ HAS THIRD
THE MILITARY. TO THE ADULT
SYSTEM FOR SOME OF THE BOOK
SERIOUS CASES. IT CLOSE BEFORE.
YOU FILE. RIGHT MANY MORE YOU
WILL BE TRIED AS ADULTS AND
SENTENCED TO A DOCTOR TERMS.
WHAT PROPOSE PROPOSAL THE
CULTURE THE J. HAD BEEN CHECKED
BALANCE PROVIDE THE- GIFT OF
WHAT RESEARCH BASED MY THAT
ENSURE. TO YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THAT WHICH IS A NEEDED OVER
BODY FOR YOUTH JUSTICE AND
HEALTH. WE THE PROPOSAL. IT HAS
G. L. MR GROUP ONE AND I THAT
THESE UP. FIRST CLOSURE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THAT JULY
AS THE CLOSE OF THE INTO DATE
ALLEGES PROPOSAL THAT A FIRM
DATE. THE J. J. ENDING IN OF
CASES IN JUNE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. BEN SHOT IN THE BE
CHANGED TRADE STORE THAT
DECEMBER. BY THE COUNTIES TO
CREATE AND APPROPRIATE. DJJ AND
THE OTHER THAT THE- RT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. COUNTIES WILL
GET. THANK TO REDUCE SEVERAL ON
DJJ M. VAN TWO THOUSAND TWO.
FUNDING FOR TO DJJ ADULT BEGAN
THIS PROCESS WHAT IN THE J. J.
OUT AS THE VIAL ALL. ARTS.
SECOND THE PROPOSAL THAT WHICH
IS HAVE PLANNING RECOMMEND BODY.
THE PLANNING BODY WITH YOU
RELATED TO. THE NEWLY IT.
OFFICE OF FUTURE. TO CREATE
POLICY THAT HAVE YOU OUTCOME
WRITTEN RELY ON INCOME. AND WE-
RATES. THIRD BLOOD BUT WOULD
THE STATE OF YOU. CALIFORNIA
HAS NEEDED A FATAL OVER THE
TREE OF YOU AND I'M SURE IT'S
EIGHT PRACTICES WHAT THE STATE
PRIORITIES FOR ARCHER. UNLIKE
MOST STATE CALIFORNIA HAS NO
SUCH AGENCY. ALL DRIVEN
JUSTICES NEEDS STRONG FEDERAL
LATER IN THE STATE YOUTH THE
SUPPORT AND PROTECTION THEY
DESERVE. IF THE STATE TRADE THE
RESPONSE OF DELIVERING SERVICES
FOR YOU THE COUNTY IT MUST NOT
ABDICATED LEADERSHIP TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AND PROMOTE EQUAL
TREATMENT ACROSS THE STATE. THE
OFFICE OF YOU JUST TO COULD
HAVE THREE DIVISIONS. THE
DIVISION OF REGULATIONS. YOU
JUSTICE RUTH POSTS CURRENTLY
SCATTERED IN DIFFERENT PLACES
IN STATE GOVERNMENT WOULD BE
CONSOLIDATED IN THE OFFICE AT
THE ADDRESS THAT. INCLUDING THE
GRANTING INSPECTION AND
REGULATORY FUNCTIONS OF THE
POOR OF AND COMMUNITY KERR. THE
AT THE HEAVILY LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR YOU BODY WITH EXPERTISE IN
THE BILL JAILS PRISONS IS NOT
AND- PLACE FOR DETERMINING BEST
PRACTICES FOR THE CARE IF YOU.
IN FACT THE BBC HAS NO LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
REGULATIONS. IT IS NOT
AUTHORIZED TO PUBLICLY ACTION
AGAINST A LOCAL AGENCY FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH EVEN THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS ESTABLISHED
BY REGULATION. THE STATE HAS NO
MECHANISM TO ENSURE EQUITY
ACROSS COUNTIES THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH JUSTICE WOULD CHANGE
THAT. THE SECOND DIVISION IS
THE DIVISION OF BEST PRACTICE
THE LEADERSHIP. IT WILL ANALYZE
DATA REGARDING ALL BUTTE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
PUBLISHES BEST PRACTICES
RESOURCES AND CREATE LEARNING
COMMUNITIES FOR YOUTH JUSTICE.
SYSTEM STAKEHOLDERS. SURE IT
WILL BE THE STATE FOR IT.
FINALLY THE DIVISION OF THE U.
S. WILL AS AN ON BUT FOR YOU
FAMILY. AND COMMUNITIES WILL
INVESTIGATE. AND REGULAR WITH
FOR THE LATEST AND FOR OF
SUPERVISORS. EXTREMELY COULD.
TO PROMOTE BEST PRACTICES IN
OVERSEE THE OF ALL USE THAT THE
LAW LEEL IS LONG OVERDUE. FULL
FEATHERS OF THE U. THE OBVIOUS
JUSTICE IS. FOR THAT
REALIGNMENT PROCESS IN FOR THE
FUTURE YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH OF THE SCALP OF OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS RANKIE GOES
ONE I HOPE THE SOUND GO UP A
LITTLE BIT MORE OKAY FRANKIE
GOES WAY WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF
YOUTH JUSTICE INITIATIVES AT
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME I AM
FRANKLY WAS MONITORING AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
A NONPROFIT LAW FIRM THAT HELPS
LOW INCOME CHILDREN ACHIEVE
THEIR POTENTIAL BY TRANSFORMING
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT SERVE
THEM. AND I ALSO HAVE TO
MENTION THAT I WAS INCARCERATED
YOU. AND SERVE SIX YEARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA ALREADY AND THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
KHLOE CAL. OUT YOU. IS
IMPORTANT. HOWEVER IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE AVOID
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES LIKE
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF JOBS
THAT ARE TRANSFERRED TO THE
ADULT JUSTICE SYSTEM. ABOUT
AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVE TO DJJ
LOCAL COURT MAY OPT AND MORE
YOU GET THE ADULTS HAVE DONE
WHERE THEY WORK THANKS PRISON
SENTENCES. IN HARSH CONDITIONS
WITH YOU OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REHABILITATION. IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED
SIGNIFICANT REFORMS AIMED AT
REDUCING ARE HARMFUL RELIANCE
ON PROSECUTING CHILDREN AS
ADULTS. EVEN AFTER HAD REDUCED
THE NUMBER OF USE PROSECUTORS
ADULT. FROM NEARLY TWELVE
THOUSAND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
TO ONLY FIFTY FOUR YEARS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES PERSIST.
ACCORDING TO DOJ DATA IN TWENTY
NINETEEN BLACK AND LATINO YOUTH
MADE UP 85% OF ALL YOU TRANSFER
TO THE ADULT SYSTEM. WITH
LATINO YOUTH NEARLY THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY THAN WHITE YOUTH TO
BE PRICED IT AT THE BILL AND
BLACK YOUTH NEARLY EIGHT TIMES
MORE LIKELY THAN WHITE YOUTH TO
BE PROSECUTED. THE CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO AVOID THE
UNNECESSARY AND HARMFUL
PRACTICE THE POCKET YOU DON'T
HIT THEM. THE LEGISLATURE
REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL INCLUDES
LANGUAGE TO MIRROR THE AGE OF
JUVENILE COURT JURISDICTION AND
CONFINEMENT UP TO AGE TWENTY
FIVE FORGET THAT YOUR TICKET
FOR THE MOST. AFFECTED THAT IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR YOU
COMMITTED TO DJJ. AND TARGET
COUNTIES FOR THE NEW FOR THE
USE OF ADULT. IN ORDER YOU. CAN
LOOK AT HOW COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY CHARGED. IN DJJ. BUT
PREVENTIVE THE TRY. OF THE
THIRTIETH OKAY THE WILL REDUCE
THE COST OF. AND LONG TERM
CHARACTER OF YOUTH. ONE
CONVENIENCE OUTCOMES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR ALL CALIFORNIA. THE
LEGISLATORS. ALTHOUGH ALSO PRE
MOST FUNDING. ADMINISTERED BY
THE OFFICE. OF YOUTH JUSTICE
FOR COUNTY TO THE HELLO CONCERN
OF CARE THAT RANGES NON READ
THE COULD COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES. THE LOCAL REGIONAL
ENHANCE WRITTEN RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES FOR REAL USED. JOHN
IS ALREADY THE MEASURE OF YOUR
LOCALLY THEY'RE ELIGIBLE BE
SENT TO BE J. J. OF THE
ESTIMATED FOR VALUES THAT
COMMIT YOU GET YOUR ELIGIBLE.
BANK ANNUALLY APPROXIMATELY.
TWO HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
ARE GOING TO BE GREAT.
REPORTLINKER STATE FARM
DESIGNED TO HELP COUNTIES
RETAIN. AND BETTER SERVE YOU
DIVIDED INTO THREE GRANT
PROGRAM. GIVEN THE JACKET
REALIGNMENT BLOCK GRANT. WE CAN
ALL GET THE THIRTY GRANT AND
USE AND COMMITTEE RESTORATION
GRANT PROGRAM. THE REGIONAL
YOUTH FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM
WILL WORK ONE TIME GRANTS ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT. HE USED TO GET THE
LOCAL FACILITY AS REGIONAL
FACILITIES FOR GEOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE LONG TERM CARE
PLACEMENTS THAT'LL BE AVAILABLE
TO OTHER COUNTY ON CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT BASED ON CONTRACT
WITH THE JUVENILE JEFF RELY A
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM HELLO
COUNTY WITH FUNDS. TO PROVIDE
COUNTY BASED COMPANY CARE AND
SUPERVISION OF RELYING YOU.
COUNTY WILL RECEIVE FUNDING
BASED ON A FORMULA THAT
INCLUDES VARIOUS FACTORS
INCLUDING A COUNTY YOUTH
POPULATION. AND THE NUMBER OF
DUES EDUCATED FOR DKK ELIGIBLE
AND- DO YOU AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION GRANT PROGRAMS WILL
WORK FUNDS TO ELIGIBLE LOCAL
ENTITIES INCLUDING GOVERNMENT
AND NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS. ON A COMPETITIVE
BASIS. BUT IT PROGRAM MUST
PROVIDE TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE AND
EVIDENCE BASED SERVICES
INCLUDING SPECIALIZED TREATMENT
PROGRAM FOR HIGH NEED NEW IN
THE AREAS OF HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE THAT THE
BETTER TREATMENT AND OTHER
SPECIALIZED AREAS OF CARE. IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DECLARED THE
BEGINNING OF THE END OF THE OF
JUVENILE PREGNANT ACKNOWLEDGE
AND MOUNTED THE BALL THE- ISSUE
AT THE DIVISION OF DEVELOPED
AFTER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTION. TO THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IN DOING
SO HE COMMITTED TO MOVING
CALIFORNIA COURT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. BASED APPROACH TO
HELPING BUTTE AND DISTRACTED
KILL DEVELOP AND LEARN FROM
THEIR MISTAKES RATHER THAN
INVESTING. IN FIFTH OF THE
CONTROL AND PUNISHMENT. AT A
TIME OF SORTS RECORD RACIAL ANY.
PUBLIC CRISES BECAUSE BY THE
AND POLICE VIOLENCE. AND
ECONOMIC RECESSION CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE WISE INVESTMENTS THAT
PROMOTE HEALTH AND RACIAL
EQUITY FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS. VANCE YOU. THE
LEGISLATURE POPOSAL
ACCOMPLISHES THAT BY CREATING
MEANINGFUL STATE OVERSIGHT OF A
RELYING DOUBLE CHECK THEM IN
FACT AND EVIDENCE BASED HEALTH
CENTER APPROACH IS DISTURBING
HIGH NEED YOUTH. ACT OF ANY
TRANSFER OF YOU. IF YOU DON'T
FIX THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER. OR CNET OF PRESENTER IS
I SHARE JACK'S IS A POLICY
ADVOCATE AND BOARD MEMBER OF
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND TO SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE OF REALIGNMENT THE
MORNING- I AM A PUBLIC POLICY
ADVOCATE I SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF. THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I AM AS A
FORMER B. S. B. C. EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE MEMBER OPERATIVE
REGULATIONS AT TITLE FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY FOUR AS WELL AS A
MENTOR CAL LOCAL SYSTEM IMPACT
THAT YOU. I WERE AS AN ADVOCATE
AT THE BY MY SYSTEM. ABSENT AT.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE A BIT
OF MY- TO SUPPORT THE EFFORT TO
CREATE. A MORE JUSTIFICATIONS
AND HEALTHIER OUTCOMES FOR YOU.
AT AGE FIFTEEN I WAS CHARGED
WITH A MURDER THAT WAS
COMMITTED BY MY PARTNER AT THE
TIME. AND THOUGH THAT THAT
CHARGE WAS. LATER REDUCED I
SPENT FIFTEEN MONTHS FIGHTING
MY CASE BETWEEN CENTRAL PARK
FIGURING OUT AND BILL MAHER
WITH YOU MIGHT ALSO KNOW AT.
EVERY DAY MIGHT WORK AT BEING
IT GIVING UP COURT I THINK
ABOUT ELEVEN MONTHS OF MY TIME
I THINK I'LL GIVE THE HALL
WHICH MOST OF MY COMMENTS TODAY
WILL REFERENCE. I WANT TO SPEND
A FEW MOMENTS SHARING SOME OF
THE POSITIVE ANALYST AT AN
ASPECT THAT. MEDICAL CLEARANCE.
I THANK THAT GIVEN OVER TENSION
OF THAT DISTANCE WOULD BE MUCH
MORE MUCH THAT IS IMMEDIATE
BANG. AGO WITH THEM. AND MY
KNOWLEDGE EXPECT EMPHASIS ON
TREATMENT. AND EDUCATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT- MICHAEL
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS WERE NOT.
A GREAT OR DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE- BUT EDUCATION WAS
ACCEPTABLE. IN FACT IT WAS
REQUIRED. I EARNED MY GED.
PACKED THE HIGH SCHOOL AT EXAM
AND CAN AND AT BOWL. OKAY THE
EDUCATE OPPORTUNITIES WITH
DIRECT BACK SUPPORT NEED MY
CONDITION HOME AT THE END OF MY
CAKE. I PARTICIPATING IN
CREATIVE WRITING PROGRAM
REGULARLY THAT FACILITATED
HEALING IN UNPRECEDENTED WAYS.
A TEACHER AND THAT PROGRAM
LATER OFFERED ME A JOB WHEN I
CAME HOME THAT WAS REALLY COULD
DO WITH THAT AND MY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. A FEW
OTHER OF THE IT COULD BE
INCLUDED. I BUILT WITH MY
MOTHER GIVES WEEKLY VISITS.
INCREASED ACCESS TO JUSTICE AS
WELL AS THE IMPROVE CULTURE AND
RETENTION. I WAS THREATENED
WITH FOURTEEN YEARS AT SOME
POINT IN MY CASE. BUT THERE WAS
NOT. TO FORGIVENESS DEFERRED
AND YOU CAN LOOK AT IT. THAT
CULTURE WAS CRUCIAL TO MY OWN
JOURNEY OF SELF INFLOWS. AND AS
THOUGH THAT THE MORE POSITIVE
ASPECT OF THAT EXPERIENCE ON
THE OTHER HAND I DO NOT RECALL
HAVING CLEAR ADVOCATE IN FACT
THAT. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT YOU
HAVE OBJECTIVE PARTY AND URBAN
PROCESSES. OR AND SHARING THE
THERE COULD BACK. REPEALING THE
TOP DIVISION ASSEMBLY HER.
SOMEONE BEING WITH MORE PEOPLE.
TEAMS FAMILY. YEAH PERHAPS EVEN
LEGAL OKAY. I LOOK FOR TO HAVE
THE POOL AT THE FOR SYSTEM AND
A GOOD MATURE TO PAY ADVANTAGE
OF THAT BUT THERE STILL MANY
ASPECTS CAN ADVOCATE SYSTEM
THAT. I WITH THE WAR THE COURT
EIGHT TWELVE EIGHT. CORRECT ON
MY PERSONAL AT THE THINGS I
THINK I SPEAK WITH EXAMPLE WE
ARE. IS STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP
WITH FAMILIES COMMUNITY. YOUR
NCDOT PRACTICAL AND RELATABLE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMMING AND
APARTMENT ACTUALIZATION. I AM
RECENT GRADUATE FROM THE OF
THOUSAND. AND I ATTRIBUTE MY
PERSONAL AND EARLY PROFESSIONAL
EXPECT TO ORGANIZATIONS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT INVESTED
IN MY DEVELOPMENT IN WYS THAT
DETENTION COULD NOT I BELIEVE
THAT A GREATER DEGREE OF
REHABILITATION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AS ATTAINABLE WHEN YOU
ARE INVESTED IN AND PEOPLE AND
ENTITIES THAT CAN HELP
TRANSFORM THEIR LIVES ARE
INVITED AND TO THE POINT
EFFORT. I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND. HELP
YOU FIND. HELPFUL THANK YOU
MUCH AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR GRADUATION FROM MISSY. OUR
NEXT SPEAKERS DANIEL MENDOZA
WHOSE A YOUTH ADVOCATE AND
JOAQUIN DANIEL. A GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CARE TO HEAR ME OKAY.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. I'M Q.
WELL MY NAME IS DANIEL MENDOZA-
I GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS
CONTENT ABOUT THE NINETEENTH
WITH THE DEGREE CALTRANS
STUDIES ARE YOU CURRENTLY WRK
WITH BOTTOM BAND OF SOMEONE
ENOUGH THAT YOU JUSTICE
ADVOCATE BASED IN STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA WE WORK TOWARD
SUPPORTING- SUPPORTING A
PROVIDED RESOURCES TO SYSTEM
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES I ALSO VOLUNTEER AT A
LOCAL JUVENILE WHOLE
FACILITATING CREATIVE WRITING
CLASSES TO INCARCERATED YOUTH
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY TO DATE
HOWEVER I STAND HERE AS A SON A
BROTHER UNCLE FRIEND. AND
OPPONENT CORSETED INDIVIDUAL.
WHEN I WAS YEARS OLD COMMITTED
TO PROTECT KING WITH MURDER. I
WOULD TRY IN ADULT AND BASIS AT
THE OF BIRDS ARE YEARS TO MY IN
PRISON. ARE YOU JUVENILE HALL
AS MY CASE MADE ITS WAY THE
COURSE. WELL I WAS. THAT DID
NOT GO TO DOCTOR. I KNEW NOT TO
REALIZE THAT WOULD PUT SPEND
THE REST OF MY LIFE IN PRISON.
I WAS FORTUNATE THAT AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS MY CASE WAS
TRANSFERRED BACK TO JUVENILE
COURT AND I SAID MY TIME AT A
LOCAL JUVENILE HALL. BECAUSE I
WAS IN A JUVENILE FACILITY OUR
RECORDS GET TO ENGAGE IN
EDUCATION. AND BEING CLOSE TO
HOME WAS HELPFUL BECAUSE I WAS
SERVED BY TEACHERS THAT. OKAY
FROM MY COMMUNITY UNDERSTOOD
ME. MY FAMILY WAS ABLE TO VISIT
ME OFTEN I WAS ABLE TO STAY
CONNECTED TO COMMUNITY
INSTRUCTORS THAT BEGAN. A
PROCESS OF BOTH THE FEELING.
HOWEVER THE LOCAL. JUSTICES
WASN'T DESIGNED FOR LONG TERM
CARE AND TREATMENT. OF LAURIE
YOU'D LIKE ME. THE FACILITY I
WAS THERE WITH THE DESIGN OR
INTENDED FOR LONG TO
CONFINEMENT. SIMILARLY
PROBATION WAS WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES ARE NEEDED SUCH AS
HIGHER EDUCATION. VOCATIONAL
TRAINING RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES ORGANISED
SERVICES THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPORTANT. TO ADDRESS MY
PROBLEM MY GROWTH AND MY
DEVELOPMENT. AS A COUPLE AFTER
COUPLE YEARS I HAD EXHAUSTED
ALL SERVICES AND PROGRAMS THAT
HAD HALTED AND THAT OFTEN.
MONEY MICROBES. BUT BECAUSE OUR
AN ADULT TRANSFERRED I WAS NOT
THE CASE IS A TAKEN. SEPARATED
FROM OF THE YOUTH. LOOK BACK
WHAT HAS HELPED ME BECOME
PERSON I AM WITH THE ABILITY TO
BE IN THE STATE. OF THE TAX
BASE WITH PEOPLE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT OPPORTUNITY THAT
WILL DEVELOP MY LEADERSHIP
SKILLS BY BOTH AND BRING
HEALING PROCESS. I WISH I HAD
GONE TO MORE OF THAT WHEN I WAS
IN THE SYSTEM TODAY AFTER WORK
AS A SERVICE PROVIDER TO OTHER
USE FOR CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. I RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE THAT ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE SHOULD BE CLOSE TO
FAMILY HY DON'T PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE THE ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION TO TRAINING SO
ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES- RESOURCES. SO
THAT WE YOUNG PEOPLE RE ENTER
BACK INTO SOCIETY THEY CAN
BECOME THE LEADERS THERE MIGHT
BE A GIVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION BERNAMA SPEAK
THANK YOU MISTER AND THOSE THAT
OUR NEXT PRESENTER IS CHAD
HEWITT WAS THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CENTER. AT YOUR HELP
INDICATION. MISTER HEWITT. ONE
MOMENT MADAM CHAIR THEY WILL
JOIN YOU SHORTLY. PARTICULATES
REJOINED US OKAY OKAY GOOD. MR
HERE YOU HAVE BEEN CALLED UPON
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME HERE. YES
I AM HERE- I WAS JUST WAITING
TO BE CALLED THE- GOOD MORNING
POSSIBLE CHAIR WEBER AND ALL
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE. ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
HI MY NAME IS CHUCK DO IT. I AM
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THIS
YEAR HEALTH FOUNDATION AND THE
CENTER AT ZERO HELP. A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA FUND
IS FOR BOYS IS NOT A COLOR.
JUST SIXTEEN MEMBER OF
PHILANTHROPIC TABLE INVESTING
IN IMPROVING OUTCOMES SUPPORT
THE MEN OF COLOR THE BAY YEAR
OF LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY REGION. I'M HERE
THIS TO SHARE OUT THE- ABOUT
MOVING CURRENT BJJ FUNDS TO
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
SHIFTING MONEY FROM ONE
PUNITIVE SYSTEM TO ANOTHER. BUT
SUFFICIENT CONTROLS TO ENSURE
THE STRATEGIES THEY WOULD
EMPLOY. CHANCE THE GOALS OF
THIS HISTORIC CHANGE. I'M HERE
TO TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES WE ALREADY KNOW
WORK BETTER FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND I'M HERE TO
EMPHASIZE THE NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT. AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT REQUIRED TO
ACCOMPLISH THE IMPORTANT TEST
BEFORE. WHEN GOVERNOR'S SOME
PERSONNEL CHIPPING THE VISION
OF YOUR BUDGET TO THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY. SAID
TODAY AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
END OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
IMPRISONMENT SYSTEM AS WE KNOW.
THIS SIGNATURE PHRASE WAS ONE
CHANGE AGENTS IN THE FIELD OF
WAITED FIGURE FOR DECADES. WE
KNOW JUVENILE JUSTICE SHOULD BE
ABOUT HELPING TO THE MAT IN A
PERSON WHO LIVES. NOT JUMP
STARTING A REVOLVING DOOR OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
LONG TIME COMMUNITY ADVOCATES
WERE HOPEFUL ABOUT THE
COMMITMENT CONSTRUCTIVE ACTION
FOR CALIFORNIA JUNE. THE
GOVERNOR NOW PROPOSING A SHIFT
THE FUNDING AND OVERSIGHT THE
COUNTY. RECOLOGY APPROACHES
CHANGE BUT BELIEVE DEEPLY THAT
THE GOALS MONTHS NOT. THE NEW
APPROACH MUST STILL BE SHAPED
BY COMMITTED TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
NOT EXPEDIENT FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. THE TRANSFORM A YOUTH
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WE KNOW WITH
IN CALIFORNIA. DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN IN A
GROWING MOVEMENT THAT TOPPLED
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND BUILD APPLE
PATHWAYS TO HELP AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE
ACCUMULATING THAT COULD BE SO
MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THINK.
YOU JUSTICE SYSTEM IS A
POWERFUL AND IT'S HEARTENING
VAMP. DEMONSTRATING RESULTS OF
THIS INVESTMENT INSTITUTION.
FOR DECADES. 93% OF YOUTH
FOOTBALL WITH THE J. J. ARE YOU
CALLING. AND EVEN IF CRIME
RATES HAVE GONE DOWN ACROSS THE
STATE AND NATIONAL. THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES OF ON THE GROUND.
WE NEED A PLAN THAT TRULY
SERGIO. CRITICALLY YOUNG PEOPLE
OF COLOR BY INVESTING IN THE
CAPACITY OF COMMUNITY THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THINK HEAL FROM TRAUMA
TO BUILD OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
TO BE SUPPORTED. SIXTY GOING
FORWARD THE PLAN MUST INCLUDE
STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT. CALIFORNIA WOULD
REQUIRE EVIDENCE NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE AN EFFECTIVE STATE AND THE
TEMPLATE THAT CAN PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT THE BJP ALIGNMENT AND
ENSURE RESOURCES ARE SPENT
RESPONSIBLY. USE OUTCOME AND
PUBLIC SECTOR. SUCH A TO SIX OF
A COUNTY OPERATED NEW JUSTICE
SYSTEM WILL BE INVESTMENTS IN
REGARDS RIGOROUS DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING AND STRONG
STATE OVERSIGHT PINE AGENCY BIG
THING YOU'VE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND NOT SIMPLY BY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. OTHER
STUDENTS THAN FICTION OR
ENTITIES CLOSELY TIED TO THE
CURRENT. CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THIS IS NOT UNIX OF.
I'M A FORMER ALAMEDA COUNTY
EIGHT TO FOR SOCIAL SERVICES A
FORMER ALAMEDA COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE DIRECTOR I KNOW FROM MY
PAST HISTORY THE STATE OF A
SIMILAR PROCESS BEEN
TRANSFORMATIVE CHILD WELFARE
CALIFORNIA BY CENTRALIZING DATA
COLLECTION IN THE STATE
OVERSIGHT OF COMING TO LOOK AT
SERVICE. YOU KNOW WHAT'S BUT
CHILDREN COUNTY. WE SHOULD
PRIME MINISTER LET THE STAY IN.
WHAT IT HAPPENED TO BEING MADE
TO SUPPORT THIRTY. AND
DEVELOPMENT TRY CAN ALSO HELP
ENSURE EQUITABLE STATE FOR THE
CAL WITH MAN TO PRIORITIZE
MONEY TO COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES. AND NO FUNDING
FOR ANY CONSTRUCTION OF STATE
OR COUNTY SECURE EFFECTIVELY
EXCEPT FOR WE PURPOSING
EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
ALIGNMENT WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
FISHING. IN FACT STRIPPING THE
DJ FUNDING ACCOUNT WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT WOULD LIKELY
DEEPENING EQUITY BY REINFORCING
THE SYSTEM OF JUSTICE BY
GEOGRAPHY. YOU'VE ALREADY
SUBJECT TO THE IMPACT OF
INEQUITABLE FUNDING AND
RESEARCH HAS ESTABLISHED A
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS LIKE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING QUALITY
EDUCATION IN THE LONGEVITY OF A
PERSON'S LIFE. AND THE QUALITY
OF THAT LIFE. INSTEAD WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THESE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES REDUCED TO
POCKETS IF YOU TRY THE BILL AND
MAKE SURE YOU JUSTICE PROGRAM
IS LIVING UP TO THE PROMISE. OF
HELPING YOUNG PEOPLE SIXTY. WE
NEED RESOURCES DEDICATED TO
COMMUNITY BASED UP ON DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS OF EVIDENCE BASED.
RESEARCH IS CLEAR ABOUT THE
INEFFECTIVENESS OF
INCARCERATION AND OF THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THE COMMUNITY
FROM GRAHAM. THE TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE NATIONAL RESEARCH
COUNCIL PUBLISHED A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
RESEARCH ON JUVENILE JUSTICE IN
THE U. S. INCLUDED THAT WELL
DESIGNED COMMITTEE PROGRAMS OFF
FOR MORE LIKELY TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. AND IMPROVE YEAH
WELL BEING BUT INSTITUTIONS
GRAYSON WHICH IS BOTH COSTLY IN
TERMS OF FINANCIAL TERMS AND-
IN FOR OF GOAL PARKER.
RESEARCHERS ALSO CLEAR ABOUT
THE IMPACT THE BRAIN AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE ON
BEHAVIORS THAT WE HAVE
CRIMINALIZED PARTICULARLY FOR
YOUTH OF COLOR. IF WE CONTINUE
THE LOCK ABOUT YOUR-
CALIFORNIA'S RECOGNIZE THEM E
NEED FOR CHANGE A RECENT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
POLL SHOWED BROAD SUPPORT FOR
EQUITY IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AT LEAST HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S OPPOSED TO STATE
DIVERSE REGION AND RACIAL
DEMOGRAPHICS VIEW THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS YOU RACIALLY
BIASED AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND THAT
PERCENTAGE RISES THE SUPER
MAJORITIES AMONG DEMOCRATS AND
INDEPENDENTS. LUCKILY WE HAVE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS TO TRUST THE
COMMUNITY BROACHES THAT HAVE
BEEN DEMONSTRATED TO BE
EFFECTIVE. WE GOT A LOT FROM
RECENT GOVERNMENTAL ACTION SAN
FRANCISCO AND LA TO SHIFT
FUNDING FOR TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY RELEVANT RESTORED OF
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDED. BY
THE BY THE BASE OF THE STATE'S.
AND STEP BY WITH. LIVE NEXT. WE
SELECT DO YOU STATE START.
GALLAGHER MOVING CALIFORNIA
FORWARD FOR THE YOUTH JUSTICE
TRANSFORMATION VISION IN THE
GOVERNMENT STATEMENT I QUOTED
AT THE BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS.
CALIFORNIA MUST NOT GO BACK
WHICH- ACCOUNT IS A MOVING IF
THEY FOR. HOPEFULLY THIS ABOUT
OUR VALUES OF THE STATE. I
APPRECIATE YOU CHAIR WEBER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
MISS JENNIFER CAMP FOR THE
PARTICIPANT HOLDING THESE
VALUES WOULD BE J. REALIGNMENT.
WE MUST REDUCE THE DISPARITIES
IN HEALTH AN OPPORTUNITY
OUTCOMES ABOUT BLACK AND BROWN
CHILDREN. EVERY CHILD DESERVES
THE OPPORTUNITY EVERY CHILD HAS
THE SAME CHANCES FOR HEALING
REHABILITATION AN OPPORTUNITY.
I URGE YOU URGE US ALL TO MAKE
THE GOOD TROUBLE. FIVE EQUITIES
JUVENILE JUSTICE REACHING YOU
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THAT BUT
YOU'RE WEBER I CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU MISTER
HEWITT TO CREATE THOSE COMMENTS
AND YOUR WORK THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH FOR SO LONG
I WANT TO OUR NEXT PERSON IS
CHIEF BRIAN **** WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT OF CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA. YES
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
RICHARD G. PROBATION OFFICER
FOR THE COUNTY OF ELDORADO. AND
PRESIDENT OF THE G. PROBATION
OFFICER THE CALIFORNIA. BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION
COURSE OFFERING MARKS ON THE
WALLS OF FOR THE NEXT
REALIGNMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AGAIN BY
REFERENCE GENE- SHE PARKS
POSITION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
CURRENT PROPOSAL WHICH IS AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE CAREFULLY CONSIDERED
OPPOSITION AFTER SUBSTANTIVE
FOR YOU AND WHAT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED TO US. WERE VARIOUS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
POTENTIAL WITH HIS PROPOSED.
I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN OUR
CONCERNS DETAILED IN A LETTER
SUBMITTED TO THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE. DIDN'T IN HERE
PRECEDING MY TESTIMONY TODAY
YOU'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES TO HOW
OTHERS WOULD SUGGEST- DJJ BE
REPLACED- SHE PARKS READY TO
CONTINUE AND THOSE DISCUSSIONS
ON THE BROADER POLICY ISSUES AS
WELL AS THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT
YOU CAN OUTLINED HERE. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW PROVISION SHEETS HAVE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF MANY
OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE REFORMS
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE GOOD
ENOUGH TO BE A ONE. YOU'RE
GOING JUSTICE REALIGNMENT OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
REALIGNMENT OF JUVENILE PAROLE.
AND OTHER BROWN'S PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH SHE PARKS
SUPPORTED. AND THROUGH WHICH WE
ACHIEVE THE RESULTS ARE
RETURNING THE AUTHORITY OF
JUVENILE TRANSFERS TO CRIMINAL
COURT. BACK WITH JUDGES RATHER
THAN THE PROSECUTORS. HERE'S
AGO WHEN THIS ONE OF TO REDUCE
NUMBER OF U. THIRTY. AFTER
PROGRAM AT LOCAL LEVEL. THEY
LOOK THE PART WITH PROBATION
AND FUNDED SERVICE ENHANCEMENTS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BY BUILDING
LOCAL CAPACITY. WHICH CREATED
OPTIONS FOR COURTS TO CONSIDER
WHEN DETERMINING THE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION FOR YOU. THE
RESULT WAS A MASSIVE REDUCTION
OF THE POPULATION CITYJET JACK.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCAL
PROBATION TO RETURN HEALTHCARE
YOU BACK TO THE COMMUNITY OR
TIMELY MANNER BUT THE SPORTS
BUT HE- CORNERSTONE CALL. IN
THAT RELY LIST THE BAY CAN. AND
BUILD CAPACITY WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES TO MAXIMIZE
SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES FORGET. THE
BREAD MORE EQUITABLE EQUITABLE
OUTCOMES ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH A CHILD. AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO NOTE THAT EVEN
THOUGH PREVIOUS REALIGNMENTS
ESSENTIALLY REDUCED WHAT SOME
CRITICS SAW AS A LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY ACCORDING TO THE
SYSTEM. WE DIDN'T SEE A RISING
CRIME WE DIDN'T SEE A RISE IN
LOCAL CAR SERRATION EFFECT
WITHOUT THE OPPOSITE. LOCAL
PROGRAMS WORK AND KEEPING KIDS
LOCAL HAS BEEN A HALLMARK TO
THE SUCCESS OF KEEPING KIDS
FROM PENETRATING DEEPER INTO
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM INCLUDING
THE ADULT PURPOSES SYSTEM. IN
FACT GIVEN THE TEN RATES OF
FALLEN BY SIXTY PER. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND TODAY. 90%
OF THE YOUTH REFERRED TO OUR
CARE ARE SAFELY AND
SUCCESSFULLY SERVED DIRECTLY IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND THEN THOSE
NUMBERS DON'T EVEN BEGIN TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE MAJORITY VIEW
CAREER FOR PROBATION. AND WHO
WE DIVERT AWAY FROM OUR OWN
SYSTEM ALTOGETHER. WE HAVE A
FORMULA THAT WORKS AND WE ARE
VERY PROUD OF THE GAINES AND
BEEN MADE OVER THE LAST DECADE.
WE CAN JUST CHANGE. BASS OF
KIDS FROM DJ. YEAH WITH THE OF.
AT A LOCAL LEVEL WE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFORMED
JUSTICE SYSTEM. THE DATA IS
CLEAR AS THE FACTION SEE POCKET
IS A DATA DRIVEN ORGANIZATION
WHAT WE TAKE A POSITION IT'S
BASED ON NOT ON CONJECTURE OR
POLITICS IT'S BASED ON WHAT'S
KNOWN. AND WHAT CAN REASONABLY
BE FORECASTED BY WHAT IS NOW.
BY RELYING ON EVIDENCE SCIENCE
AND DATA TO DRIVE DECISION
MAKING PROBATION WAS ABLE
ARCHER AND USE OF A SMARTER.
SAFER AND MORE COMPASSIONATE
WAY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
JUSTICE. WE CHANGE THE CULTURE.
IN PROBATION. INSTAR COMMITMENT
TO PRIORITIZE THE SERVICE TO
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR HOLISTIC
APPROACHES MAINTAIN COMMUNITY
SAFETY. WITHOUT ABILITY IS JUST
ONE OF THE MANY KEYS FOR
SUCCESS WITH THE COMPASSION WAS
ANOTHER REMAINING FOCUSED ON
NEEDS FOR A INFORMED LENS HELPS
FOSTER THAT COMPASSION. WE
PROVIDE EXTENSIVE TRAINING FOR
OFFICERS TO WORK WITH YOU MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND COMPASSIONATELY
AND USING AN EVENT SPACE FOR
AND WORK TOWARD REHABILITATION
HELPS KEEP YOU FOCUSED ON
HEALTHY PATHWAYS. BUT BECAUSE
WE EVIDENCE. ENGAGEMENT WEEK.
IN THIS DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT
THE EIGHT HUNDRED OR SO THINK
THE JJ. WE WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO DISCUSS WHAT ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY EXISTS TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM ABOUT TEN THOUSAND YOU.
CAN BENEFIT FROM SHE TALKED
PROPOSAL PROPOSED THE RAISE THE
AGE OF JUVENILE COURT
JURISDICTION. A PLAN WHICH
INCLUDES THE BROADER
IMPLEMENTATION OF BEST
PRACTICES ACROSS THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WORKS TO
ADDRESS RACIAL INEQUITIES IN
THOSE YOUTH CENTER PROBATION.
PROBATION OPERATES ON THE
PHILOSOPHY OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT. CHANGES OUR
BUSINESS MODEL AND WE SUBJECT
OURSELVES TO THAT FRAME WORKERS
WHILE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
CAN SHE FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS
BRAIN BREAKING WITH THE SCIENCE
AND RESEARCH STATES AND USING
THAT TO GUIDE OUR EFFORTS TO
FURTHER. EVOLVE ARE OBSESSED.
WHEN WE MADE. A COUPLE OF A- WE
RELIED ON THE- OF RESEARCH
ADULT BRAIN SCIENCE THE EIGHT
AND NINETEEN YEAR OLDS ARE. MAY
CRASH DECISIONS THAT IGNORE
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES FOCUSING
RATHER ON IMMEDIATE GAINS.
BREAKING NEWS JOURNAL COURT
JURISDICTION FROM SEVENTEEN TO
NINETEEN CORPORATE WHAT
RESEARCH TELLS US IS
COMMONSENSE ARE MERGING DOGS
ARE MORE AMENABLE TO
REHABILITATION BECAUSE THEIR
BRAINS ARE STILL DEVELOPING AND
THEREFORE CAN INCORPORATE ADOPT
NEW WAYS OF THINKING WE GET A
LASTING CHANGE. TO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT PROGRAM CRIMINAL
JUSTICE POLICY MANAGEMENT
HARPER KENNEDY SCHOOL NOTES
THAT A MERGING OF DOGS COMPRISE
A DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF ARRESTS IN THE U.
S. EMERGING ADULTS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MAKE UP TEN
PERCENT. OF THE US POPULATION
BUT 30% OF THE REST. FOR THOSE
OF US WITH OLDER TEENS IN OUR
LIVES THAT'S NO MYSTERY WE SEE
PLAY OUT REGULARLY IN THE
DECISIONS THAT MAKE. THE SAME
STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO REMAIN VIGILANT
JUSTICE SYSTEM RATHER THAN
BEING PROSECUTED THE ADULT
SYSTEM. ARE UP 277% LESS LIKELY
TO BE ARRESTED BURKE BY. THOSE
PROSECUTED AS ADULTS WERE ALSO
MORE LIKELY TO BE REARRESTED
FOR MORE VIOLENT CRIME THAN
THOSE LOS. IN OUR VIEW REYES IN
A JURISDICTION WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS NEED OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
LEARNING HOW TO MAKE A CHOICE.
BUT BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN ALWAYS DO BETTER OUR
PROPOSAL DOESN'T STOP THERE. IN
ADDITION TO PROPOSING TO RAISE
THE JURISDICTION WE SHOULD
DEPARTMENT SEVERAL BEST
PRACTICES ACROSS OUR STATE BY
ALIGNING OUR APPROACHES IN
CODE. TO SERVE YOU. TO THE
LEVEL OF NEED AND RISK WHILE
STILL LEVERAGING THE
FLEXIBILITY ANDINNOVATION OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO OBTAIN
THAT STANDARDS. OF COURSE A
CONVERSATION TODAY THIS
SURROUNDING REWRITING YOU THE
DJJ CALIBRATION APARTMENTS. AND
PROBATION CHIEFS IN THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT'S WOULD
BEAT ARE PREPARED TO HELP THE
STATE SHAPE. WHAT IS NEEDED TO
REALIGN DJJ COUNTY PROBATION
MUCH LIKE WE'VE DONE IN
PREVIOUS REALIGNMENTS. WE
SHOULD RELY ON THE SUCCESSFUL
BUT TO GUIDE EFFORTS GOING. WE
KNOW BY WE'VE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL
PITFALLS. FROM THE BUS. IT MUST
INSTALL COMPANY IN OUR JOB
SYSTEM PARTNERS THAT CAN
ABILITY. AND REHABILITATION OUR
ALL A- WITH THE MAKAN OF THE
NEW MODEL. ABSENT THAT NO
AMOUNT OF DISINCENTIVES WILL
PERSUADE THEM FROM PURSUING A
COURSE OF WHAT THEY PERCEIVED
TO BE PUBLIC SAFETY OVER WHAT
WE KNOW TO BE BEST FOR YOU.
GAINS WE HAVE MADE OVER THE
LAST DECADE MUST NOT BE MARKED.
BY COULD FORMS FOR THIS IF AND
EFFECTIVE DATES ARE MET
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED NEEDS TO
BE COURT FOUND TO HAVE
COMMITTED MUCH SERIOUS
OFFENSES. PROBATION CAN AGAIN
HELP THE STATE EFFECTUATE
SIGNIFICANT MEANINGFUL CHANGE
HOWEVER WE MUST FOCUS ON A FEW
THINGS. WE MUST BE ABLE TO
TAILOR PROGRAMS SERVICES AND
CAPACITY AND DELIVER A MESSAGE
TO THE EACH EACH YEAR AT BEST
SIR. DON'T RESTRUCTURE THE PLAN
REPLACEMENT. IT WITH ANOTHER
SHIP STANDARDS COLLECT DATA AND
INCENTIVIZE BEST PROPER SHOES.
THE BUILDING OF THE ROCKER HAS
NEVER HELPED HILL CHILD. TRAUMA
AS WE CANNOT. OR IN YOUR BURKE
MAKE SCENARIO WHEREBY THE RELY
OF DJ. ARMS ARE. WITH NINETY
PER OF THE JUNE SYSTEM THAT ITS
CURRENT MANAGED LOCAL. SCHOOL
SUPPORT MUCH BE STABLE AND
SECURE. BY WRAP UP BY SAME
PROBATION AS HAVE WITH MANY PER
REFORM STAND ABOUT WITH THIS CA
AND THE ADMIN TO ACTUATE THE
RECLINER OF DJS COUNTY IN A WAY
THAT IT'S ARE GOALS WE'LL WORK
HARD INVESTED IN TRAINING TO
CREATE MORE HEALTH FOCUSED
COMMON FORMED TO COMPASSIONATE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
DIVERTS THE MAJORITY YOU. AND
TREATS THOSE WITH HIGH NEEDS
WITH AN INDIVIDUALIZED
APPROACH. I AM VERY HEARTENED
TO HEAR THE COMMENTS FROM-
SHAKERS BEFORE ME ARE SO MUCH
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THOSE OF OUR
OWN AND- WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN HERE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO FOR
RECHARGE WHERE THEY ARE
PRESENTER IS CHIEF TONYA
HARTMAN WHO IS FOR THE SOUTH
REGION CHAIR AND LEGISLATIVE
VICE CHAIR OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
WEBER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM TONYA HEISMAN CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER FOR SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND SEE POP
SOUTHERN REVENGE REGION CHAIR
AND THE VICE CHAIR OF A
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
OUR APPROACH TO REALIGNMENT IS
INFORMED BY THE ELEVATE JUSTICE
ACT CONTAINED IN SENATE BILL
EIGHT EIGHT NINE. BEYOND
RAISING THE AGE OF JURISDICTION
TO FOLLOW BRAIN SCIENCE WE'RE
SEEKING TO CODIFY BEST
PRACTICES TO MORE FULLY SET
STANDARDS THAT ALIGN APPROACHES
IN LAW TO BETTER SERVE YOU.
THESE INCLUDE TO LIMIT
CONDITIONS OF PROBATION IMPOSED
BY THE COURT TO ONLY THOSE
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND THE RISK FACTORS
IDENTIFIED THROUGH A RESEARCH
BASED RISK ASSESSMENT. TO ADOPT
INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENT AND
REHABILITATION PLANS THAT OUR
FAMILY CENTERED STRENGTH BASED
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
BUILT AROUND INCENTIVES AND
REWARDS RATHER THAN SANCTIONS.
TO FURTHER REDUCE DETENTION
CONDITION IT ON A RESEARCH
BASED RISK ASSESSMENT AND THE
MOST IMMEDIATE AND URGENT
SITUATIONS AS WELL AS ENSURING
FOR REQUIRING THE USE. OF A
RESPONSE MATRIX FOR YOUTH ON
PROBATION TO BETTER INFORM
THOSE CRUCIAL DETENTION
DECISIONS THAT CAN HAVE SUCH
LASTING CONSEQUENCES. AND
INCLUDE AS PART OF THE WORK OF
EACH COUNTY'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
COORDINATING COUNCIL AND
EXAMINATION OF THE PREVALENCE
OF RACIAL ETHNIC GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION DISPARITIES.
AND STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES IDENTIFIED. ALONG
WITH MOVING AWAY FROM THE
UTILIZATION OF OUT OF STATE
PLACEMENTS AND BUILDING
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA TO SERVE THOSE VIEWS
WITH ACUTE TREATMENT NEEDS SB
EIGHT EIGHT NINE WOULD GO FAR
IN ACHIEVING GREATER SUCCESS
AND IMPROVED OUTCOMES IN OUR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OVERSIGHT IS IMPORTANT WE AGREE
THE STATE SHOULD MONITOR
SUPPORT AND DEMAND OUTCOMES.
PURSUANT TO STATUTE AND
GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITIES ARE
CURRENTLY OVERSEEN BY THE
JUVENILE PRESIDING JUDGE THE
GRAND JURY THE DELINQUENCY
PREVENTION COUNCIL THE BOARD OF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
THE FIRE MARSHAL AND THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE COORDINATING
COUNCIL. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF COLLABORATION
WITH OTHER DISCIPLINES AND
PERSPECTIVES WE'VE ALSO ENGAGED
ADDITIONAL ENTITIES AND
REVIEWING OUR OPERATIONS BEYOND
WHAT IS REQUIRED BY LAW. WE
SEEK OUT THE MOST EXPERIENCED
KNOWLEDGEABLE EXPERTS WHILE
ENSURING THEIR WORK IS ALIGNED
WITH OUR VALUES AND FOCUS ON
POSITIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
MANY PURSUE ACCREDITATION FROM
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE INSTITUTE
FOR MEDICAL QUALITY R. I. M. Q.
THE NATIONAL COMMISSION ON
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE.
PERFORMANCE BASED STANDARDS AS
WELL AS COUNTLESS INDEPENDENT
AUDITORS THAT REVIEW OUR
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND THE
QUALITY OF OUR CARE. WE ALSO
WELCOME VOLUNTEERS AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS INTO OUR
FACILITIES EACH DAY TO PARTNER
WITH US AND STRENGTHEN OUR
EFFORTS. I'M PROUD OF THE
COUNTRY'S TRANSFORMATION THAT
HAS OCCURRED SINCE I FIRST
ENTERED THIS BILL THIRTY YEARS
AGO. WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO EVERY USE THAT AS AN OUR
CARE. AND AS A MOTHER I FEEL A
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
EVERY MOTHER GRANDMOTHER AUNTS
OR OTHER LOVED ONES WITH THE
CHILD AT ONE OF MY FACILITIES.
IT NEEDS TO BE IF YOU PATH AND
THE TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DORT CANNOT BE TAKEN LIGHTLY.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT WE ARE
NOT JUST ANOTHER FAILED SYSTEM
BUT THEY WILL CYCLE THROUGH.
THE DJJ POPULATION HAS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT RISK AND NEEDS AND
WILL REQUIRE NOTHING SHORT OF
OUR BEST RESEARCH DATA
EXPERTISE AND COMMITMENT. AS
EXPERTS IN JUVENILE JUSTICE WE
NOTE INEQUALITY IN SERVICES CAN
ARISE FOR YOU. WE MUST BE
COGNIZANT OF THE GAPS IN
CAPACITY. NOT ALL COUNTIES HAVE
CAPACITY AND SOME THAT DO MAY
NOT HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
CAPACITY. WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL
OF THE TREATMENT MODALITY AS
WELL AS THE SPACE TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE SAFETY NEEDS OF THE U.
WE DESPERATELY NEED SPACE
SPACE. THAT CAN BE USED TO
CREATE ENVIRONMENTS THAT REDUCE
STRESS NOT ADD TO IT. WE'RE
PROUD OF THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION DETENTION ACHIEVED IN
CALIFORNIA. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IT WOULD BE PRUDENT TO LOOK AT
INCENTIVISING COLLABORATION
WITHOUT BUILDING IN LAYERS OF
BUREAUCRACY AND PUTTING UP
SILOS SILOS THAT WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY HARM THE YOUTH WERE
TRYING TO HELP. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN IMPORTANT
WORK OF DIVERSION AND QUALITY
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION SO THAT
WE DO NOT JEOPARDIZE THOSE
SEPARATE WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN
REDUCTIONS IN THE TO PROVIDE
POPULATION AS WELL AS DECREASED
ATTENTION. WITH PROPER
INVESTMENT SUPPORTS PROBATION
CAN SUCCESSFULLY INCORPORATE
ADDITIONAL USE AND MAINTAIN AN
APPROPRIATE AND SUPPORTIVE
LOCAL JUVENILE CONTINUE ON. BUT
WE CANNOT RISK THE REFORM
EFFORT THAT WILL RESULT IN MORE
USED IN THE ADULT SYSTEM. THIS
PLAN MUST GIVE CONFIDENCE TO
COURTS AND OTHERS THAT THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM CAN ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE POPULATION. IF WE
DO NOT INSURE THIS CONFIDENCE
WE WILL SEE AN INCREASE IN
ADULT FILENE'S AND GREATLY SET
BACK THE PROGRESS MADE SO
RECENTLY. IN CLOSING AS I
VISIT. OUR FACILITIES TO SIT
AND TALK TO THE USED IN ART.
AFTER THE LEASE TRUST UNIT IN A
SPACE THAT HAS BEEN
RECONFIGURED TO SERVE LIKE A
FAMILY ROOM IN SOMEONE'S HOME.
RATHER THAN INSTITUTIONAL DAY
ROOM. I REMINDED THAT WHILE
THERE IS STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
AND I WATCHED THE YOUTH IN OUR
CARE SHARE THEIR ARTWORK ORANGE
OR A AN OLD FASHIONED WATER
BALLOON FIGHT ON A HOT DAY. I'M
REMINDED WHY WE WORK SO HARD TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE CHILDREN. IF
DONE WELL THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO MUCH MORE
TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM WHILE
KEEPING OUR CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY. PLEASE NOTE THAT THE
PROBATION CHIEFS ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE BETTER OPTIONS FOR ALL
YOU KNOW JUSTICE SYSTEM. THANK
YOU AGAIN AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. OKAY WANT TO THANK. CHIEF
OF HEIGHTS MEANT THAT'S THE
THIS IS THE LAST OF OUR A
PANELIST TO PRESENT INFORMATION
TO US I WANT TO ASK OF THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR LA-
THEY'RE ON STANDBY IF ANY THAT
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE THEIR HERE
AVAILABLE FOR US IF THEY HAVE
ANY COMMENTS NOW WE CAN TAKE
SOME OF THOSE IF THEY'D LIKE TO
ADD SOME OTHERWISE THEY WILL BE
ON STANDBY FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE. IS ANYONE
IN LA- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS ANY COMMENTS TO MAKE IT
THIS TIME. AND THIS IS AMY
JARVIS AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
JUST A COUPLE MINUTES OF YOUR
TIME. AND THAT WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH THE PROPOSAL NOW AND
THAT WE RECEIVE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. WE'VE BEEN TALKING
TO SOME OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING. THAT CHEAP PROBATION
OFFICERS AS WELL AS ON THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. I THINK THEIR
PIECES WERE WHERE WE CAN
PROBABLY REACH AGREEMENT I
THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WERE STILL. AND WE STILL
WANT TO CONTINUE DISCUSSING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. I'M
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE HERE BY ALL THE PANELISTS-
AND YOU FEEL LIKE THERE ARE.
MANY AREAS WHERE WE HAVE COMMON
GROUND. I AM I THINK A COUPLE
OF THE THINGS THAT I JUST
WANTED TO THE SITE AS- SOME.
MORE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS IS
THE TINY I'M AND WHILE I AGREE
THE INTENT IS NOT JUST TO
ADDRESS A PHYSICAL SITUATION.
IT IS ALSO ABOUT THE RIGHT
POLICY WE DO THINK THESE YOU
CAN BE SERVED BETTER IF THEY
REMAIN LOCAL. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
RETAIN. I'M TERMS THE TIMING
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL
ALLOWS- COMMITMENTS TO CONTINUE
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND ARE SORT OF IN A WAIT AND
INTAKE AS OF JULY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- AND THEN SLOW ATTRITION
OVER TIME. I THINK WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE TINY AGAIN WELL
IT'S NOT FISCALLY DRIVEN THERE
ARE FISCAL IMPLICATIONS OF
DOING THAT. AND WE ALSO THINK
IT'S REALLY. THAT WE- THAT. TO
AND I. IT'S THAT YOU. HAVE SIDE
TODAY. I'M THEY HAVE ME GREAT
REST LOCALLY. AND HOT ACHIEVE
REALLY GREAT OUTCOME AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT MOMENTUM
I'M- FOR THE- POPULATION IT
REMAINS TO THE STATE. I THINK.
THE OTHER THING THEY I. LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO. IS CREATION OF AN
INDEPENDENT. WITH HELP SERVICES
AGENCY. I'M THE ROLE OF THE
BOARD IT STINKS. SINCE THE PLOT
POINT. I'M AYE AND IS IT BAD
THAT. CONTEMPLATED IT HARPER.
SOMETHING THAT WE DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT FOR I THINK WE ARE
OPEN TO AND I OF YOUTH ADVOCATE
OFFICE AND OR SOME AN AUTUMN
MEN TYPE POSITION WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WHERE WE CAN
PROBABLY FIND SOME COMMON
GROUND- I THINK ANOTHER
CRITICAL PIECE FOR US IS HAVING
IN- OPTIONS FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE. AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF OPTIONS THOSE THAT
EXISTS NOW SO THAT WE DON'T
ENCOURAGE. MORE ADULT COURT
COMMITMENTS THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO US
THEM IS KEY O OUR PROPOSAL ALL
ALONG- WE STARTED WHEN WE
PROPOSED MADE THE PROPOSAL. AT
A COST OF A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USE THAT
WOULD BE REALIGNED TO THE
LOCALS AFTER MUCH DISCUSSION
AND WE INCREASED THAT TO TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR YOUTH. WITH A FLOOR
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COUNTIES THAT HAD-
THAT WAS LOWER THAN WHATEVER
THAT I HAD MATH AND THAT BE.
I'D SO I WANTED TO KNOW THAT I
THINK AND THERE IS ALSO A
COMMENT MADE ABOUT THE COST OF
OUR INCARCERATION AT THE STATE
LEVEL. OUR PER CAPITA COST IS
EXPECTED TO BE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THIS COMING YEAR AND I
THINK LOCALLY THOSE THERE ARE
SOME VERY BIG VARIATIONS I
THINK ON THE HIGH END SANTA
CLARA IS ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR YOU. OTHER
KEY SMALL COUNTIES ARE ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. LA IS
CLOSER TO AROUND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND SO I'M NOT I'M
NOT JUSTIFYING OUR COSTS BUT I
DO THINK WE DO HAVE VERY.
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS BECAUSE
OF THE FEDERAL LAWSUIT WHICH WE
ARE NOW NO LONGER SUBJECT TO
BUT HAVE AGREED VARIOUS.
RELATIONS AND WE HOUSE ARE YOU.
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE
AGREEMENTS I AND WE PROVIDE THE
TREATMENT SERVICES CONSISTENT
WITHOUT LAWSUIT SO. I DID JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT- I THINK THE
OTHER THING THAT WE DID WAS
RECOGNIZING THAT NOT ALL
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO REPLICATE. OR AND OPERATE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THOSE- THAT
ARE UNIQUE TO THE STATE LEVEL
SYSTEM LIKE THE SEX BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT PROGRAM THAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER. WE DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS AN
INCENTIVE FOR COUNTIES TO
CREATE THOSE PROGRAMS WHICH IS
WHY WE ALSO ESTABLISHED. SOME
PLANNING MONEY WITHIN- THE
BORDER STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO COUNTIES FOR THAT
FOR PLANNING PURPOSES. I'M IN
OUR INTENT WOULD BE TO OVERTIME
DEVELOP THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES LOCALLY RECOGNIZING
THAT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO EXIST IN EACH COUNTY WE
THOUGHT OUR REGIONAL APPROACH.
WOULD WORK AND THAT HAPPENS NOW
OUR CAPPIES THE CONTRACT OTHER.
TONY FOR PRESIDENT GRANT WAS.
UP THEY I JUST A JUVENILE HALL
FIRST BT THERE ARE SERVICE AND
FOR. IN THE CAN. I MUCH OF
THOSE THAT WERE TO BY THE
ADVOCATES EARLIER AND- IN THIS
HEARING. SO THOSE ARE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WOULD CONTINUE
UNDER THIS MODEL OUR INTENT IS
NOT TO BREAK THAT. BUT OUR
INTENT IS TO MAINTAIN LOCAL
DISCRETION WHILE ALSO- INSURING
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM. FOR
THOSE JUDGES THAT MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOUSING OF
THESE JUVENILE OFFENDERS. SO
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
HADN'T WANTED TO COVER HERE AND
I YES THAT DOUBLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANYONE FROM THE L. A.
O. WHO HAS ANY COMMENTS THAT
THEY LIKE TO MAKE THIS TIME.
MAKE IT TOMORROW HELLO I WOULD
JUST NOTE A FEW. CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE A RT ALSO A- IN
THE LUNCH. PROPOSAL SO ON THAT
TIME. WHILE THE LET'S TAKE A
PROPOSAL DELAY THE- STOPPAGE OF
AND TAKEN TOLD TWENTY TWENTY
THREE IT WOULD ALLOW FOR.
COUNTIES TO BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COUNTIES EARLIER- AND- DO
YOU SEE THE FISCAL INCENTIVE TO
DO SO. AND THEN. IN TERMS OF
YOU BEING SENT TO POTENTIALLY
BEING SENT TO ADULT COURT THAT
ALLEGED PROPOSAL WOULD ACTUALLY
INCLUDE A FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVE FOR COUNTIES TO
THANK YOU TO ADULT COURT
BECAUSE THOSE WHO WOULD BE
SENTENCED TO PRISON- COUNTY
WOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY FIFTY
DOLLARS MARGINAL COST FOR THE
FULL DURATION OF THE PRISON
TERM. IT FISSION IN TERMS OF
THE REGIONAL APPROACH THAT WILL
TAKE CHARGE APPROACH DOES ALSO
INCLUDE OPPORTUNITY FOR
COUNTIES TO CONTRACT WITH EACH
OTHER TO PROVIDE HOUSING AND
ALSO WORD OF ESTABLISH A
REGIONAL GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD ALLOW FOR COUNTIES TO
DEVELOP HUBS FOR MORE
SPECIALIZED SERVICES WHICH
WOULD BE OFFERED. ORIGINALLY
NOT JUST TO WITHIN THEIR OWN
COUNTY THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THAT BRINGS IT
BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE OR
THE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS YES WAS JUST DON'T.
SO A LOT OF THIS DISCUSSION TO.
HINGES ON SOMETHING THAT REALLY
HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED TO THESE
PROPOSALS AND THAT'S
FACILITIES. BECAUSE IF COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING ON OR-
FORGIVE YOU LOOKING TO COUNTIES
TO BE PROVIDING SOME REGIONAL.
SUPPORT THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
RIGHT FACILITIES AND A AND A
LIKE THIS NOTION OF NOT JUST
CAPACITY BUT APPROPRIATE
CAPACITY. BECAUSE THERE IS A
GREAT DEAL CAPACITY AT THE
COUNTIES TO. BECAUSE A LOT OF
THEM ARE HALF OR OR LESS FULL
BUT THOSE FACILITIES MAY NOT BE
APPROPRIATE IF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS. THE RIGHT KIND
OF PROGRAMMING AND I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS IS THE NEED. TO
UPDATE SOME OF THOSE FACILITIES
AND NOT JUST PARKING FACILITIES
BUT ACTUALLY SOFTENING.
FACILITY SO THAT THEY CAN BE
MORE HOME LIKE THAT THEY CAN BE
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THE KINDS
OF PROGRAMMING. THAT THESE
THESE YOUTH REALLY NEED SO
FORGET HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM I THINK WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE LACK OF FACILITIES
NEEDS IN IN JUST FOR EXAMPLE
CARRY THAT I COME OUT OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY. UNDER THE OLD C.
Y. EIGHT DAYS CAN YOU REFUSE TO
SEND KIDS TO THE STATE BECAUSE
OF HOW BAD THINGS WERE. INSTEAD
OF THE SAME TYPE AND WORKED
VERY HARD TO DIVERT KIDS SO
THEY HAD A VERY SMALL
POPULATION. AT THE JUVENILE
HALL AND BECAUSE OF THAT WHEN
IT CAME TIME FOR FUNDING THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET FUNDING TO
UPDATE THEIR FACILITIES SO
THERE A LOT OF COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN DOING A LOT THE RIGHT
THING. OVER THE- INTERVENING
YEARS BUT BECAUSE OF HOW THE
CAPACITY LOOKS IN AND PREVIOUS
FUNDING DECISIONS THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT FACILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE KIDS SO I THINK
WE NEED TO AS IN PARALLEL. WITH
THE EFFORT OF THIS REALIGNMENT
IS REALLY LOOK AT THE CAPACITY
ACROSS THE STATE THE KINDS OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE THERE AND
SEE IF WE NEED TO BE PROVIDING
SOME UPDATES. TO THOSE CABINETS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE NEED TO BE
SPENT UP TO PROVIDE REGIONAL
SERVICES AS WE MOVE FOR WOOD
WITH. THIS PROPOSAL SO THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY ADDRESSED HERE.
SO AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. IN PARALLEL
TO THIS IS REALLY LOOK AT WHAT
THE CAPACITY IS AT EACH COUNTY
INSTEAD OF JUST SAYING YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL BEDS WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE MORE
KIDS. THAT'S NOT FAIR TO THOSE
COUNTIES WHO MAY OR MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
FORGET EXPECT THAT REGIONAL
APPROACH TO WORK WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SUPPORT THOSE COUNTY IS
WILLING TO STEP UP. FOR THOSE
REGIONAL SERVICES AND HELP
COUNTIES AROUND THE- YEAH. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. JONES
SAWYER YES AND THANK YOU OUT OF
IT AND I HEARD HEARD A LOT
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY AND IF THE
SYSTEMS WERE WORKING-
ACCOUNTABILITY WHETHER ON. ON
THE PROVISION SIDE OR OR THE
STATE SIDE ORDINATE COMMITTEE
BASE ORGANIZATIONS SITE UP WE
WOULD BE MEETING HERE RIGHT NOW.
IF THERE WERE IF PEOPLE HAVEN'T
TRULY BEEN ACCOUNTABLE AND THE
SUCCESS. AND SO I I'M I'M
ALWAYS WONDERING WHAT WHAT
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. AND I USUALLY
USED TO THINK THAT THE EXAMPLE
OF- WORKING IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WE GET REALLY PRIDEFUL ON WHAT
WE CALL WHICH IT SAID. WE GAVE
THIS PROGRAM WE GET THAT PART
READING PROGRAMS IN THE CLASSIC
TIGHTEST SOCIAL WORKED ALL THIS
WILL BE AT THE FRONT END. AND
THEN WHEN YOU ASK THEM ABOUT
THEIR OUTCOMES YOU GET THIS
KINDA MUMBLES- THE- MUMBLE
JUMBLE AND I JUST REMEMBER IT
WAS A CAR COMPANY. THAT DID A
LOT OF RESEARCH PUT IN A LOT OF
EFFORT ON DISCARDED THEY WERE
IN SELF TO LATINO COMMUNITY.
AND IT WORKED REALLY GREAT AND
THE IN A POLLING AND EVERYTHING
THEN THEY PUT IT OUT INTO
MARKET. AND I CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY THE CARD DIDN'T SELL. DISK
LATINA JUST WOULD NOT BY THE
CAR. AND ONE DAY THEY WERE
TALKING TO SOMEONE IN ELECTION
OR IN UPPER MANAGEMENT AND HE
SAID WELL THE CAR'S NAME IS
NOVA. IN IN IN IN SPANISH NOVA
MEANS DON'T GO. WHY WOULD YOU
WANNA CARDUS SAYS WON'T RUN
WON'T GO. AND IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE WE DO ALL THESE
WONDERFUL THINGS IN THE FRONT
END AND THEN WHEN YOU ASK FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE BACK IN-
YOU DON'T GET A WHOLE YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS SO AND SO
WHEN I WHEN SOMEONE SAYS WE
SPENT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR KIDS A THREE
HUNDRED TO SEVENTY FIVE OR
WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS I NEED
TO TAXPAYERS. TO KNOW. WHAT
BANG FOR THE BUCK DID THEY GET.
AND SO I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW- FOR BOTH SIDES REALLY.
DID YOU SET UP ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES RESET THE OUTCOMES
THESE WERE THESE ARE GOALS
THESE ARE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AND IN THE OUTCOMES ARE
GOING TO BE A. B. C. INDEED IF
YOU DON'T REACH THOSE. DO YOU
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO YOUR BUDGET
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO YOUR
PROGRAM DO YOU MAKE IT JUST. OR
DO YOU JUST TO KEEP DOING THAT
AND EXPECTING A DIFFERENT
RESULT. OF WHAT WE CALL PEOPLE
WHO DO THAT AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT REALLY REALLY
DRIVES ME CRAZY I DO NOT I'M
NOT FIGHTING OVER. WHO GETS THE
MONEY UP FIGHTING OVER WHO BEST.
GET THE MONEY. IT 1100% OF IT
WENT TO PROBATION AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THEY DID A-
THEY DID THE BEST JOB POSSIBLE
INTERESSES MINIMUM RATE WAS
DOWN ALMOST TO ZERO. THEN WE
NEED TO GIVE EVERY DIME TO
THEM. BUT IF IT ISN'T IF IT IS
THE CBO'S AND THEY'RE DOING THE
BEST JOB POSSIBLE DO WE NEED TO
GIVE IT TO THEM OR IS IT A
HYBRID OF THAT. AND IT SHOULD
BE BASED ON THE SUCCESS RATE OF
THEIR- KIDS. NOT ON PEOPLE
BUILDING AS SOMEONE SAID
BUILDING BUREAUCRACIES ARE
BUILDING NEW BUREAUCRACIES. AND
SO I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT. I
CAN BACK INTO WHAT MEASURES OF
SUCCESS. ARE THEY USING. WHEN
IT FROM. BOTH SIDES- OUT TO
COMMUNITY OR WITHIN- WITHIN
WITHIN GOVERNMENT. WHAT ARE
THOSE MEASURES OF SUCCESS
BECAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR A WHOLE
LOT OF THAT. IN ALL OF THIS
DISCUSSION AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY THE MOST CRITICAL
THING. ANYONE ELSE SEVENTY
QUESTIONS. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS I THINK YOU RAISE
SOME IMPORTANT ISSUES EVERYONE
HAS RAISED SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES AND- AND AS WE'VE SEEN
THE NUMBERS GO FROM TEN
THOUSAND DOWN TO EIGHT HUNDRED
AND- YOU KNOW WE CAN. PROBABLY
STAND UP AND TAKE A BOW WE
THINK WE CAN BUT WE HAVE TO
REALIZE THE EXTERNAL PRESSURES
THAT BROUGHT US TO THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED THAT IT MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN BECAUSE WE HAVE DEVELOPED
SUCH A GREAT SYSTEM TO REDUCE
IT TO THAT LEVEL THAT WHAT
NUMBER OF ALL- CHALLENGES AND
OVERSIGHTS AND YOU KNOW LEGAL
THINGS AND WHAT HAVE YOU THAT
MADE US AND AS WE DO EVEN WITH
OUR- OWN OF PRISON SYSTEM THAT
WE'VE- HAD REDUCE NUMBERS. YOU
KNOW AND THAT KIND OF THING AND
SELF SO THAT BRINGS US TO THAT
BIG CONCERN I THINK WE HAVE
SEEN- AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND RECOGNIZE THAT WE'VE
SEEN AS AS I SAW HERE THE
NUMBERS THE TREMENDOUS
DISPARITY BETWEEN. THE COST
THAT'S THERE AND I THINK THE
PUBLIC NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND IT
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE COST- YOU
KNOW- WHEN I FIRST GOT INVOLVED
OF WODEHOUSE FIRST ON THIS
COMMITTEE I THINK THE COST WAS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR PER
CHILD. NOW IT TOO CLOSE TO
SOMEONE SAID FOUR HUNDRED AND
MUCH OF IT HAS NOT AND MOST OF
IT IS NOT TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT WE'VE INCREASED SERVICES
AND OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
THAT WE ARE FUNDING THESE
FACILITIES- AND THESE-
INSTITUTIONS OF THESE BUILDINGS
AND THE STAFF THAT'S THERE. AND
YET WE WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
INCREASING THE SERVICES AS WE
IS ONE WOULD THINK AND SELL- SO
THAT THAT HAD ME SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED BECAUSE I FELT IT TWO
AND A FIFTY THOUSAND I COULD
PROBABLY DO A BETTER JOB WITH
HELPING FAMILIES AT PROVIDING
STABILITY IN COUNSELING FOR THE
FAMILY SO THE KIDS COULD BE
BETTER OFF SERVING. AND THAT'S
IT I'M GOING ON GOAL WHICH WILL
CHANGE THE SENATE WE ARE.
RECOGNIZE THE CAR OF. WHEN I
WOULD GET WHAT WE WERE GOING.
TO HAVE THE T RESOURCES THAT
AND THAT AND THAT BECOMES. UP
SOME OF THE CHEESE MAY BE ABLE
TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE WE HAVE
SOME FOR THAT SOME REAL REALLY
LOW I KNOW IT I AM IS AND IN
ELDER. THERE'S A THREE P. AND
IN THE YOUTH IN THE DO HALL AND
THEY'VE BUILT A NEW FACILITY
AND I'M WONDERING IF WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS ARE WE PREPARING FOR A
DIFFERENT KIND OF- SERVICE
CENTER OR DELIVERY CENTER OR
WHAT THAT'S GOING ON WITH OUR
WITH OPENS A LOT OF A JUVENILE
HALLS OF PRETTY EMPTY- AT THIS
POINT AND I'M WONDERING WHAT WE
ARE WE PREPARING I HOPE WE'RE
NOT PREPARING TO FILL THE
THAT'S NOT ONE. BECAUSE I
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SAY IF YOU
BUILD SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
THEY WILL COME THEY WILL BUILD
IT THEY WILL FILL IT BUT ARE WE
PREPARING OUR ADJUSTING THOSE
OF WHO ARE A POLICE CHIEF OF
THAT OUR OF PROBATION CHIEFS
ARE WE ARE WE PREPARING TO
RENOVATE. FACILITIES TO MAKE
MORE. USEFUL APPROACH. FOR OF
THIS. ARE WOULD DEALING. OF
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE DEAL OUR
WE JUST. YOU KNOW I I'M TRYING
TO I'M TRYING TO IMAGINE THIS I
KNOW WE SHUT DOWN SOME
FACILITIES IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BECAUSE OF WITH. THE CAPACITY
WASN'T THERE AND I'M NOT SURE
IF THAT. IF THEY SHUT DOWN THE
RIGHT ONES ARE NOT BUT- ARE WE-
I WHAT ARE WE PREPARING TO DO
WITH THE SITUATION OF HAVING.
THESE FACILITIES- AS MR STONE
TALKS ABOUT. APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES. ARE THE ONES WE
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE ONES ARE
WE DOING THINGS WITH THEM.
BEFORE WE GO OFF ON. A DOING
SOMETHING ELSE THAT MIGHT.
INCREASE THE OF THE COST OF
GETTING NEW FACILITIES OR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF THE SALUKIS
AT ANY OF THE CHIEFS ABLE TO.
PROBATION CHIEFS ABLE TO GIVE
US SOME INSIGHT AS TO WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH FACILITIES. SINCE
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT THE- BILL
THE LOW NUMBER OF FOLKS IN
THOSE FACILITIES IN THE
VARIOUS. AREAS IS ANYONE WHO'S
ON THE WORK ON THE ON THE LINE
ANYONE OF OUR PROBATION CHIEFS
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON
FACILITIES. YES MANAGER
DESCRIBED RICHARD. ELDORADO
COUNTY PROBATION CHIEF. AND
WHICH BROUGHT ABOUT THE WILD
WILD CALLED CORRECT THE RECORD
JUST A LITTLE BIT- ARE
AVERAGING POPULATIONS BETWEEN
TWELVE AND FOURTEEN THE EPISODE
A BUILT FOR FORTY- WE ACTUALLY
RECENTLY CLOSED A FACILITY WE
HAD AN EIGHTY BED CAPACITY.
FACILITIES ELDORADO BUT- THE
ECONOMICS OBVIOUSLY- DID NOT
BEAR OUT SO EVEN THOUGH IT
SERVED OPPOSITE ENDS OF OUR-
WIDE COUNTY WE SHOT THAT
WHATEVER TO FACILITIES ABOUT. A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO- WE ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF. CONSTRUCTING A
NEW TWENTY BED FACILITY TO
REPLACE ALL OF OUR CAPACITY-
WITH A- WITH A CONTEMPORARY.
STYLE OF FACILITY WE'VE GONE
ACROSS COUNTRY AND OUTSIDE THE
BORDERS OF THE U. S. TO FIND-
AN ARCHITECT WE CAN. BUILD FOR
US SHE STATED THEY ARE STILL.
THAT WE ACTUALLY. SERVE THE
NEEDS OF A JUVENILE JUDGE.
PARTY AND ONE THAT WE WOULD
ANTICIPATE FOR THE NEXT THIRTY.
YEARS SO WHEN WE'RE OF
FACILITIES CAL. BROADEN MY
COMMENTS ABOUT THE OVER NOW.
AND SAY THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
COULD PASS A AND- BECAUSE THERE
ARE LOW. AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATIONS MOST OR ALL OF THE
FACILITIES. YES THERE ARE SOME
THAT ARE CLOSING DOWN AND
OTHERS THAT ARE BEING JEAN
THAT. THEIR LOW POPULATIONS-
BUT- RELATIONSHIP HAVE FOCUSED
ON IN RECENT YEARS IN RETOOLING
THEIR FACILITIES AND CREATING
MORE HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENTS
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF
STRUCTURES THEY HAD. THAT SAID
IT WOULD BE FANTASTIC IF PART
OF THE SOLUTION- PERFORM GOING
FORWARD FROM HERE WAS TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO RETOOL EVEN
FURTHER THERE ARE SOME BRICK
AND MORTAR FACILITIES THAT- IF
GIVEN THAT THE RIGHT TECH
RESOURCES. COULD BE
REHABILITATED AND FACILITIES
THAT- THAT WE WOULD BE PROUD TO
HAVE OUR USE OF LIVING IN HIS
HOME LIKE ENVIRONMENTS AND
THAT'S THE FOCAL POINT OF ALL
OF THE TRIPS WE KNOW WHAT WE
WANT ONE OUT- HAVING THE LOCAL
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO INVEST.
INTO A STRUCTURE WHERE THERE
ARE ONLY A FEW KIDS UP THE HARD
ARGUMENT TO MAKE LOCALLY WHEN
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
COMPUTING RESOURCES COMPETING
INTERESTS FOR THOSE RESOURCES
OUT I THINK SOME WOMEN STONE
MENTIONED THAT IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY- THAT THEY HAD THAT THAT
THAT PROBLEM WE HAVE THAT
PROBLEM ALL OVER THE STATE BUT
WE HAVE DIRECTED RESOURCES FOR.
FOR SPECIFIC PURPOSES LIKE
THAT- I KNOW COUNTIES WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN UTILIZING US
FUNDS. TO RESTRUCTURE AND
REBUILD. OKAY RIGHT WELL YES AS
PROBABLY I DIDN'T ON THAT
SOMEONE ELSE ON HE WAS NOT OKAY
SURE IT'S BRINGING WITH
NATIONAL CENTER THOUGHT TO RISK
HELLO I DON'T THERE WAS A LOT
OF QUICK A LOT OF TIME REQUEST
ADDRESS YOU KNOW WHAT IS UNDER
AND MAYBE NOT I JUST ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS PROPOSE FOR THIS WE-
AND I WANT ON THE TWO ISSUES
WITH RESPECT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
AS WELL AS THE ISSUE OF
SPECIMENS. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE IN- IN
TERMS OF JUST YOU KNOW JUST.
THE BALLOT IN A PATROL THE
RULING THE- THAT THAT MAY OF. A
HELP PAGE BRING MORE. AND
REALLY FOCUS YOU THE- BY. A
STATE THAT IS ACTUALLY HAVE
EXPERTISE IN YOUTH ISSUES IT IS
NO LONGER ACCEPTABLE OR
APPROPRIATE. TO ALLOW. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CORRECTIONS.
OFFICIALS TO DICTATE WHAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST WHETHER
REHABILITATION DEVELOPMENT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE EXPERIENCED.
SIMILAR CARDS THEIR LIVES WHICH
IS WHY WE PROPOSE AN OFFICE IF
YOU KEPT. THAT WOULD HAPPEN
REGULATORY FUNCTIONS THAT WOULD
HAVE BEST PRACTICES AND
RESEARCH. CAPABILITY TO PROMOTE
EVERY QUICK BACKTRACK. AND HANG
BACK THAT KNOWLEDGE. TO GRANT
MANAGEMENT AND AS WELL AS
HAVING THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
ADVOCATE AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THAT. BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
MANY COUNTY JAILS. IN LIGHT
BLUE. AND CALL THEM GET
APPROPRIATE RIGHT AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
MOVE AWAY FROM I'VE HEARD
COMMENTS. FROM THE PROBATION
CHAIRS- ASKING FOR MORE MONEY
TO RENOVATE GIVEN ALL THAT I.
YOU KNOW I DON'T I WOULD LIKE
TO PUT BACK ON THANK THAT WE
NEEDED MORE FACILITY BONE. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IN YOU HEARD
FROM DANIEL MENDOZA EARLIER
THAT MULTI DON'T PEOPLE COULD
BE AFFECTED BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY. SO BUT I DO HAVE TO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
FACILITIES THAT ARE LACKING-
YOU KNOW SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE THAT HAS A VERY
TINY OUTDATED TO ALL. THAT IF
THEY WANTED TO YOU KNOW BUILD
THE PROGRAM WOULD NEED
IMPROVEMENT AND WE'VE
ACCOUNTED. THERE IS A GOOD YOU
KNOW THE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
GRANT I DESCRIBED EARLIER THAT
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE. TO
COUNTY. RENOVATOR GROUP THERE
PROGRAM I'M NOT IN. TO MAKE
THEM TOUGH BUT TO ME THEM TO BE
MILLION. AND TO HOW HIM. I
SPENT SEVEN. SEVEN EIGHT MY
RATHER IN INVENTOR. YOU CAN ALL.
IT WAS THE MIDDLE TIME THERE
WAS BRASS. I NEVER GOT TO SEE A
TREE. IF OF BRIEF FOR AIR KNOW
RIGHT. CHURCH I. BECAUSE WE'RE
VERY LIMITED. AND I TO SAY BY
GOING TO. WAS FELT LIKE A BOY
TO. I ACCEPT THERE BE THEY DID
HAVE A- SPACES PROBE. AND HE'LL
GO OUT TO RUNNING AND EXPECTS
DO OF THE- THINGS ALL. IN A
PRISON LIKE FACILITY. BUT THEY
HAD THE SPACE. SO I DON'T. WHAT
WHAT WHAT I ALSO WANT TO IS
THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE. AT
CONCERN ABOUT ALLOWING TO LONG
HAUL TO BE YOU AS LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY. BECAUSE OF THIS
KIND OF. ITS COUNTER EVIDENCE
BASED WE SHOULD NOT HAVE HIT
THE BRICK AND MORTAR. YOU KNOW
FACILITY THAT YOU KNOW THAT ARE
STILL LIVING WITH CORRECTIONS
OFFICERS- YOU KNOW. DOING
RAISING THEM WE DID FOR
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. PUBLIC
HEALTH. ORGANIZATIONS PUBLIC.
IN THE COMMUNITY AT CHECK YOU
WOULD MANAGE THAT A LOT OF THE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT ARE LARGELY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE PRODUCTION AND USE A
CORPORATION OF RECIDIVISM.
BECAUSE WE NEED THE WAY AT THE
STATE AND THE NATION I WOULD
ARGUE. FROM INCARCERATIONS
INCARCERATING KIDS AND SO- DID
THE BILL I MEAN IF THIS
PROPOSAL. IF APPROVED DATA
COLLECTION ANALYSIS THAT THE
BLOCK GRANT THAT WE MENTIONED
EARLIER. REQUIRES COUNTIES TO
SUBMIT A PLAN. AT YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY WOULD USE THE MONEY FOR
WHAT TYPES OF EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES FOR WHAT POPULATION.
AND ALSO REPORT OKAY- THE
FACILITY GRANTS ARE COMPETITIVE
IF AND ALSO THE INNOVATIVE%
GRANT PROGRAMS. IF WE FIND OR
AT THE STATE FIND THAT- LOCAL
COUNTIES ARE NOT MEETING. WHAT
THEY PROMISED THATTHEY- WILL
NOT BE REFUNDED AND SUBSEQUENT
YEARS AND SO THE GOOD PART OF A
COMPETITIVE GRANT- PROGRAM IS
IT ALLOWS. THE BEST.
APPLICATION TO GET THE FUNDING
WHAT THE DAY THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO MEASURE UP AGAINST WHAT
THEY PROMISED AND THEY ACTUALLY
DELIVER. AND THE WRITTEN
CONSEQUENCE WILL BE THAT THEY
WILL NOT RECEIVE. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NOT BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW. IS WELL THOUGHT OUT IT IS
TO THE- LITTLE AND I BELIEVE
THAT A PROBABLY WHAT MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNING TO THE
STATUS QUO BUT THERE WILL BE
OVERSIGHT THE MOBILE. DATA THE
L. AT THE MEASURE. LONGER
RESTORATION BUT YOU THOUGHT
FRUIT OKAY YOU MUCH I DON'T
THINK MOST OF THE LESSONS I
WERE JUST ANSWERED BY YOU WITH
REGARDS TO A BILL AND PRO A
FACILITY AND A WHOLE OF OTHER
THING AS WELL AS OF THE OTHER
ALL AGREED THAT MANY OF
QUESTIONS THEY HAD BEING AT
WORK BEING BY. I MAY TAKE IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEES OR ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS I THINK ALL OF
US GOT ANSWERED THAT LAST
RESPONSE OUT AT THAT POINT THEN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND- AS WE MOVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WANT TO SEE FIRST OF
ALL DOES ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO'S PHYSICALLY IN THIS ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A ONE
MINUTE COMMENT I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT YOU HAVE A ONE
MINUTE COMMENT WHICH MEANS. YOU
CAN SAY I'M YOUR NAME THE
AGENCY REPRESENTED WHETHER NOT
YOU'RE IN FAVOR OR OPPOSED TO
THE- THE PROPOSAL BUT NO-
DISCUSSIONS BASICALLY OF THE
RATIONALE FOR YOUR POSITION SO
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THIS
ROOM WHO HAS A WHO WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A COME PLEASE YOUR HAND.
OKAY THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF ANY.
THAT ARE IN THIS ROOM WE THEN
WILL GO UP WE WILL CHECK IN-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE-
BASICALLY TO THE VARIOUS SITES
FOR TESTIMONY THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF REMOTE SITES
THAT ARE HERE THAT ARE THERE
THERE. ARE WE HAVE REMOTE SITES
IN SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO.
FRESNO VAN NUYS LOS ANGELES AND
SAN DIEGO SO THIS IS PROBABLY A
BIG BILL. THE MOST AT THE
BROADEST REMOTE SITE. LIST I'VE
SEEN THUS FAR IN ANYTHING
HEARINGS HAVE BEEN AND- SO IS
THERE ANYONE IN SACRAMENTO. AND
WHAT AT THE REMOTE SITE IN
SACRAMENTO. IF YOU ARE PLEASE
GIVE YOUR NAME. THE AGENCY
REPRESENT AND WHETHER NOT YOU
IN FAVOR OPPOSED TO THE-
POSITION IS THE OPERATOR IN
SACRAMENTO. WELL THERE'S NO ONE
IN SACRAMENTO OKAY WHAT ABOUT
SAN FRANCISCO'S ANYONE AT SAN
FRANCISCO AT THE REMOTE SITE.
THERE'S NO ONE AT ANY LOCATION.
OKAY VERY GOOD- THAT THEN
BRINGS US TO THE TELEPHONE ARE
THERE ANY- EIGHTY PERSONS
WAITING OPERATOR THE IN THE ARE
THAT ANYONE'S ON THE PHONE WHO
HAVEN'T COMMENTS TO MAKE.
ANYONE PLANNING ON THE PHONE
THEY ARE. THERE ARE MADAM
CHAIRMAN CHAIRWOMAN- PARDON ME-
THE- WE HAVE PEOPLE IN KILL.
AND FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS. ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY AN
OP WILL ANSWER PHONE LINE
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WHEN I CALL YOU TO
SPEAK IN OPEN YOUR LINE
ALEXANDER FOR YOU BY YOUR LINE
NUMBER. MADAM CHAIR WE'RE READY
FOR THE FIRST PERSON AND WE ARE
NOT COMPLYING NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
SANDEEP AND PIANO AND I AM A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WHAT THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESPECT. I
WOULD LIKE TO URGE THE
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY BASED
ALTERNATIVES OUT YET FOR THE
CLOSURE OF DKK. AND MEDIABASE
ALTERNATIVE WHAT ABOUT THE
COURT YOU IN A NONCITIZEN YOUTH
BEING IMPACTED. BY THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM NONPARTISAN USE
CASES ARE HAD A I THINK YOU
OUGHT NOT ALWAYS HAVE THE TIME
FOR IS YOU TO GIVE YOUR NAME
AND WHETHER NOT YOU'RE IN.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE TO THE
PROPOSAL. ONE IS GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR POSITION. WELL
NOW GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE ONE
SIXTY THREE OF ONE OF THE OPEN.
THANK YOU- THE MADAM CHAIR DEAR
LUCIEN- HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE
LEAGUE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. AND THE
LA SCHOOL OF POLICE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION- ALIGNING WITH-
COMMENTS- THAT. LAYS MADE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY THE
NEXT ONE OPERATOR. WINOKUR
SEVENTY LINE SEVENTY OF LINES
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA BEHALF THAT URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
JUST REFERENCE THAT COUNTIES
THE SPENT CONSIDERABLE TIME- IN
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION IS TO DESIGN
A SYSTEM I THINK THAT MEETS THE
GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
EXTENSIVELY THROUGH TODAY'S-
HEARING- WE ARE INTERESTED IN
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO A- STATE
COUNTY PARTNERSHIP THAT IS THE
HALLMARK OF THE PREVIOUS
REFORMS- THAT OFFERS THE
RESOURCES PROTECTIONS AND
FLEXIBILITIES THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO ENCOURAGE THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF SERVICES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THIS COMPLEX-
THAT THE PUBLIC NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH POPULATION WE WANT THESE
KIDS TO DO BETTER WE UNDERSTAND
THE BENEFITS OF KEEPING THEM AT
HOME AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE DESIGNED A SYSTEM THAT DOES
NOT RESULT IN MORE KIDS AND
BEING UP IN THE ADULT COURT
SYSTEM WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. THANK YOU
NEXT PERSON BLIND. LINE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW WE
NOT BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE DJ DAY REALIGNMENT WE HAD
ARE VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
COUNTY BILITY THE OFFER THE
LEVEL OF SERVICES AND
PROGRAMMING THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED SINCE THE CONCLUSION OR
RESOLUTION OF THE FOR A
LAWSUIT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR NEXT PERSON. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. RABIA WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY JUSTICE
CONSTRUCTS OF COURT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT PERSON. LINE
SEVENTY THREE. MY NAME IS ROSE
ONE EVENT THE PRESIDENT OF ONE
OF SUBSTANCE MEN OF HONOR ARE
WE STANDING AGREEMENT ALIGNING
WITH THE COMMENTS PROVIDED BY
FRANKIE COUPONS WE SERVE BOTH
THE FOSTER YOUTH AND DJJ YOUTH
ALONG WITH OTHER USED IN THE
VARIOUS JUVENILE FACILITIES- WE
ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CROSSOVER FOSTER YOUTH THAT ARE
ENTERING THAT WOULD BE SENT
DIRECTLY TO PRESIDENT SO WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS BEHIND FRANKIE. GOES
MONTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PERSON LINE FORTY. YES THIS IS
SUPER RAIL FROM THE JUVENILE
CENTER THE COMMITTEE IS
CONCERNED ABOUT EXACTLY THE
RIGHT THING WE SUPPORT THE
ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE SEVENTY ONE. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO I NEED HELP. YES.
YOU HAVE A COMMENT THE
PRESIDENT WILL. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON RIGHT FIVE. BY TWENTY
CAPITAL ONE IS OPEN YEAH MY
NAME IS TERRY NICHOLS I'M A
TEACHER CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
AND I REPRESENT THE TEACHERS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE ACTUALLY ARE YOU ONE
THOUSAND- WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. BECAUSE THE VOICES OF
THE TEACHERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DOING THE WORK IN THE FRONT
LINE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
THIRD BECAUSE THIS COMMITTEE IS
MEETING AT TEN O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING. FOR THE TEACHERS ARE
AT WORK IN RELY THAT THAT MANY
DESPITE. PROGRAMS ARE NOT BEING
ADDRESSED IN THIS BILL OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR NEXT
CALLER. LINE THIRTY BILL. BY
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING COUNTY STOCKTON
TOLD HIS DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
PRESENTED TODAY THANK YOU. K.
MEXICO LINE FIFTY ONE. NINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TRACY WHITE DJ CABLE
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION AND- WE
OPPOSE THE CLOSING OF DJJ THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FORTY FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME'S JOSE DENOUNCED
FIFTH GRADE CHAPTER PRESIDENT
IN A JUNIOR HE CHRISTOPHER. AND
I'M IN THE OPPOSITION OPPOSING
AS FAR AS SHE WAS ALL SET BASED
ON THERE WASN'T A LOT OF TALK
ON THE ACTUAL 1% THAT. IS WORKS
ACTUALLY SENT TO G. DAY THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES AND ABLE
TO DO THE CARE WITH THE
PROGRAMS AND ALL THE ASSESSMENT
THAT WE DID FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY GO OUT TO BE TO THE-
LEFT OF THE RECIDIVISM RATE
THAT THEY ARE SUCCESS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO HEART BUBBLE THAT
WOULD POP. THANK RIGHT THANK
YOU UHHUH. NEXT CALLER. ONE
MOMENT MATTER CHAIR. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE QUEUING UP
THE OPERATORS ARE PROCESSING ON.
WE WAIT THANK COMMITTEE FOR THE
PAGE OF THE ANOTHER. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THE LINE IS OPEN. AT THE
ROAD WORLD ALWAYS CLOSE AT THE
PRESIDENT AMHERST WRONGLY
OPPOSED THE- THANK YOU WHAT
ABOUT TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER. STRUCTURE THE
MOMENT MADAM CHAIR. WE'RE GOING
TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN. HI MY
NAME IS FAMILIES YEAH I AM AN
EMPLOYEE DJ AND I SEE THE STATE
RUN DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE NEED TO REMAIN OPEN IF
ANYTHING DANGEROUS H. OF KIDS
PERMITTED IN DJ SHOULD BE
EXTENDED WITHOUT BEING SENT AYE
OPPOSED THE CLOSURE AND DJ
THANK. YOU HANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVENTY SIX YOUR MIND IS
OPEN. M. LINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
MIND IS OPEN PLEASE TAKE. OKAY
WE'RE GOING ON TO LINE EIGHTY.
PINAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S MIGUEL GARCIA ON THE
POLITIKER NADIR WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I JUST
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND REITERATE
THE COMMENT EARLIER BUT MADE A
PILOT TO MEET CALVIN THANK YOU
GOOD MIND AND THE ADVOCATES OF
THE COMMUNITY THAT THERE WILL
BE A NEED FOR A COMMUNITY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE BUILT-
ALSO AS WELL THAT I AM IN FAVOR
OF THE PROPOSAL NOT. TO GET
THANK YOU YES YOU OKAY GOOD
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL LINE
EIGHTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS
THOMAS GORDON I HAVE WORKED
WITH THE DJJ FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
I OPPOSE THESE PROPOSALS I FEEL
LIKE WHAT MISS CALVIN CHIEF
RICHARD SAID WERE CORRECT THAT
IMPROPER CLOSING WHAT IS THE
GAME THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE- LEGISLATION
A CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE STOP WILL PROPOSAL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE SOME LATE ENTRIES
WERE PROCESSING THEM RIGHT NOW
WILL BE JUST ANOTHER MOMENT.
LINE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE NO LONGER HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL OUR QUESTIONERS AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR AND
THANKS TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
ACTUALLY TOOK THE TIME TO CALL
IN AND TO BE A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION OUR THEIR COMMENTS.
A QUESTIONS BY THE MEMBERS. OF
WANT TO THANK YOU. A READ WHAT
WE SAID A COUPLE YEARS AGO IN
TERMS OF THIS WHOLE CONCEPT OF
MOVING DJJ. THAT IT'S NOT JUST
A MATTER OF MOVING UP ACOSTA
FROM ONE AGENCY TO THE NEXT IF
WE DO THAT THEN WE REALLY
WASTING OUR TIME- AND AS A
RESULT IT WILL DEFINITELY
RESULT AND- CHANGING PROGRAM
SOMETIMES CHANGE IN STAFFING
CHANGE AND FOCUS AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS HAPPEN WHEN
YOU. ACTUALLY DO A DEEP DIVE
AND YOU REALLY WANT TO CHANGE
AN AGENT SO. I CAN UNDERSTAND
THE ANGST AND THE CONCERN OF
THOSE WHO CURRENTLY WORK IN THE
SYSTEM IS WHERE WHERE THEY FIT
IN. HOPEFULLY THEIR INPUT IN
THE BEST THAT THEY HAVE TO
BRING WILL BE UTILIZED IN THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE NEW JUVENILE SYSTEM A
SYSTEM WILL LOOK LIKE. I THINK
WE ALL AGREE ON THE ON THE
BASIC ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOME ACCOUNTABILITY WE
WANT SOME CONSISTENCY. SOME
SERVICES PROVIDED FOR STUDENTS
AS YOUNG PEOPLE I JUST KEEP
SAYING STUDENTS THAT'S MY-
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE BUT UP.
AND THEY ARE STUDENTS MOST OF
THESE FOLKS ARE STUDENTS AND IT
WILL CONSISTENCY IN SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED ACROSS THE
STATE SO THAT AS WE SAID BEFORE
GEOGRAPHY WILL NOT DETERMINE
YOUR SUCCESS. IN OUR JUVENILE
SYSTEM BUT. WE ALSO WANT
RECOGNIZE THAT WE WANT TO GET
TO POINT WILL BE ARE MAY A- IN
A LOT OF YOUNG. SO THAT THERE
IS NO TO ANY OTHER KIND OF
JUVENILE SYSTEM WE'VE REDUCED
OUR POPULATION BUT WE KNOW WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB IN THE
PROCESS OF THAT. AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR WAYS THAT THAT
MAKES IT BETTER IN TERMS OF
WHAT TO DO- AND WE HAVE NOT
THUS FAR IDENTIFIED ONE SIZE
FIT ALL WE KNOW THAT EACH
COUNTY IS GOING TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT CHALLENGE. AND HAS
AND HAS DIFFERENT FACILITIES
AND RESOURCES THAT NEED TO BE
UTILIZED BUT THE OUTCOME SHOULD
BE THE SAME THE KID SHOULD BE
BETTER AS A- OF HAVING. TO THAT
SYSTEM AND THEY SHOULD BE GOING
OUT AS PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS WERE
ABLE TO MANAGE THEIR LIVES AND
BE A CREDIT TO THEIR COMMUNITY
AND THEIR FAMILIES- AT FAMILIES
COULD BE. AS A ALSO THE PEOPLE.
BROUGHT IT TO THAT. THANK WILL
THOSE BE ISSUE THAT ARE THERE
ARE GETTING TO THE DETAILS
GOING TO BE MOST AND PART I
THINK THIS COMMITTEE IS COMING
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN HAVE A ROLE IN
MAKING AND- THAT THE OVERSIGHT.
IS THERE. AND THEN WE HAVE A
COUPLE. TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
AND HAVE A CO. IN MAKING THE
OUTCOME. OR PROVIDED FOR US SO
THAT WE FEEL. THAT WE KNOW THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'RE PUTTING
INTO IT ACTUALLY MATTERS WE
HAVE NOT. A NONE OF US HAVE
SAID THIS IS THE AMOUNT THAT
YOU HAVE AN ONLY THAT IN TERMS
OF WHAT. RESOURCES NEED TO BE
THERE AND SO IS NOT ABOUT
CUTTING COST. AT IT'S ABOUT
BASICALLY CUTTING WASTE SURELY.
BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT SAVING
LIVES AND I THINK THAT'S OUR
MAIN FOCUS- AND FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. THAT A BE IN THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT WE DO AT
THIS MOMENT. WILL DETERMINE
WHAT THEY WILL DO FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES AND WHAT THE
COMMUNITY WILL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH. AND SUPPORT AS PEOPLE
MOVE FORWARD. SO I WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR COMING
TOGETHER FOR THIS DISCUSSION
I'M SURE THIS IS. THE BEGINNING
A MANY DISCUSSIONS WE WILL HAVE
A DJJ. I'M PLEASED WE'VE MOVED
THIS FAR I THINK THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS WE'VE BEEN. KIND
OF CONCERN THAT WE SEEM TO BE
STYMIED IN ONE PLACE OF PEOPLE
JUST COULD NOT COME TO MOVE.
AND BRING CHANGE AND I MAY HAVE
BEEN BECAUSE- OF FOLKS IT TOO
MUCH IN IN THEIR OWN MIND
VESTED INTEREST AND MOVEMENT.
OR NO MOVEMENT I SHOULD SAY.
AND SO HAVE. TOGETHER FINALLY
WITH SOME RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PROPOSALS AND THIS WE KNOW THAT
MANY MANY MORE PIECES TO GO
WITH IT. I'M HOPING THAT THOSE
WHO ARE. CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN
COMMITTED THIS WILL STAY WITH
THE PROCESS AND THAT THE- THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL
AS THOSE. TWO SHOULD. AND
FASHION FOR US WHAT WE KNOW
WILL BE A MUCH BETTER. SYSTEM
FOR THE FOR THE- OF. CELL OF
THIS IS SO ONE OF ME. STEP THAT
WE HAVE TAKE. THIS WHAT I WANT
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME.
AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK
ALL OF THOSE WHO TESTIFIED FOR
US TODAY IN THOSE WHO CAME. UP
FOR GIVING THEIR INPUT AND
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL HANG IN
THERE WITH US AND CONTINUE WITH
THE PROCESS. I HAVE A GOOD DAY.